Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sollte man eigentlich die AfD verbieten?
War die jemals erlaubt?
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 475 vom 10. November 2023.
Das heißt wir haben jetzt nicht mal mehr einen Tag und dann geht's wieder los
mit der närrischen Zeit.
Ach herrje.
Ich hoffe du hast dein Kostüm schon eingeklappt.
Ja klar natürlich Kostüm. Aber das sieht man doch nicht am 11 .11 ist doch ohne Kostüm.
Ja, keine Ahnung, ich bin ja nicht von da.
Ich kenne mich ja nicht aus mit der Kultur. Aber du bist da ein bisschen eher
dran. Liebchen, ich bin auch nicht aus Köln.
Ja, aber du hast das wahrscheinlich mitbekommen.
Karneval habe ich mitbekommen.
Ja, ich nicht.
Warst du mal da?
Beim Karneval? Ich war beim Karneval in, aber nochmal Tim, Karneval ist im Frühjahr.
Ist mir ja egal. Verfassen wir das jetzt einfach mal.
Guck mal, wenn man nicht drin steckt in solchen Sachen, dann kann man auch einfach
generalisieren bis der Arzt kommt.
Also in Düsseldorf gibt's Karneval, in Köln.
Du hast einen Tipp mit dem Hillau.
Köln is a love. Meins hab ich vergessen.
Meins war ich nicht gewesen.
Da weiß ich nicht.
Das ist nicht meins.
Jede Jacke ist anders, aber meins ist das nicht.
Ne, genau, ja gibt's. Ist aber Rosenmontag hauptsächlich, dem Rosenmontagszug.
Und ja, man muss sehr viel trinken und versuchen sich schlecht zu benehmen,
aber nicht scheiße. Das ist auch ein schmaler Grat.
Das gelingt dem einen besser als dem anderen.
Ist ja aufgefallen, dass in Berlin auch so ein paar Verrückte versucht haben,
Karnevalskultur nach Fasson des, wie nennt man denn dieses Gebiet? Halloween.
Halloween versuchen die hier. Die standen letztens vor der Tür und wollten einen auf den Fressen.
Die haben hier sogar einen eigenen Schlachtruf oder wie nennt man das,
was ist das, Alav und Helau, was ist das so rein sprachgrammatikalisch,
worum handelt es sich dabei?
Um einen was? Ausruf?
Gruß.
Gruß?
Ich weiß es nicht, ich weiß es nicht.
Wofür steht denn das? Was ist das für ein Moment in deinem Leben, wenn ich das sage?
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht dein bester Moment.
Ich sag das ja auch nicht.
Ein Ausruf, ist es ein Ausruf?
Ein Ausruf, ein Narrenruf.
Ein Ausruf, ja.
Ein Narrenruf, genau und in Berlin wollten sie auch irgendeinen Narrenruf machen.
Und wer hat da irgendeine Werbeagentur?
Das hab ich mich halt auch gefragt, wer steckt denn da so dahinter und ich hab's
auch schon wieder vergessen was es sein soll.
Ah ja hier, hey,
hey, hey, yo, abgeleitet von den Begriffen Heiterkeit und Jokus.
Alterkeit und Joghurt, sind das nicht so Moderatoren im ZDF?
Ich glaub ja. Alterkeit und Joghurt.
Das ist ja, okay, das ist… Karneval an Havel und Spree, ole, ole, ole.
Also eins kann ich dir sagen, Berlin und Karneval, das wird nie stattfinden.
Karneval der Kulturen.
Weißt du, was die Unioner singen?
Ole, ole, ole.
Union braucht keinen Karneval, Unioner feiern überall.
Das singt man dann immer, wenn man gewonnen hat gegen Mainz.
Also lange nicht mehr gesungen, ne?
Naja, zuletzt nicht mehr so oft.
Deswegen interessierst du dich jetzt auf einmal für Karneval?
Aber Mainz und Köln kommen erst noch.
Kaum verlierten Union mal neun Spiele am Stück interessiert der Tim.
Zwölf.
Ich wollte jetzt den Finger nicht so in die Wunde halten, aber interessiert
der Tim sich für Karneval?
Linus, erzähl mal, sag mal, Köln, ne?
Wie ist das dann? In Düsseldorf, die haben doch auch gute Laune, wenn die verlieren, ne?
Komm, wir schalten mal zu unserem Korrespondenten und gucken mal,
wie das eigentlich im Süden so aussieht. Thomas, hallo!
Hallo!
Entschuldigung, dass du unsere schlechten Witze so lange ertragen musstest.
Bevor wir dich dazu holen.
Ich bewundere die fremden Kulturen. Also Halloween hat es bis zu uns geschafft,
Karneval nicht wirklich, aber dafür beginnt bald die Ballsaison.
Es gibt keinen Karneval in Österreich?
Ballsaison?
Stimmt, die haben Ballsaison.
Opernball!
Das ist so ähnlich.
Da haben die ihre Massenschlägerei auf der Straße. Da hat jeder seine traditionellen, weißt du?
Also die Opernballdemo hat wirklich Tradition. Da gehen Leute schon seit Jahrzehnten hin.
Das ist wirklich ein Happening. Auch mit Kostüm.
Was ist denn da?
Sehr angetrunken, auch schlechtes Benehmen.
Wer geht denn da hin?
Opernball, ja Thomas kann das erzählen.
Ja, aber da gehen auch nicht alle hin.
Viele Leute gehen auf Bälle. Es gibt da mehrere, auch manche,
die angeblich ganz gut sind. Ich war noch nie auf sowas.
Ich bin ja ein schlechter Österreicher und es gibt den Opernball,
das ist der größte, der ist auch der konservative Teil der Regierung und Kanzler
und Präsident und alles.
Und dann gibt es aber auch Zuckerbäckerball, es gibt einen Regenbogenball,
es gibt alle möglichen Bälle.
Und that's a thing in Vienna seit vielen, vielen Jahrhunderten eigentlich schon. So Walzer und so Zeug.
Ja gegen Walzer, also Walzer ist okay.
Ist der einzige Tanz den du kannst, sicher. Ich?
Nee.
Nee, kannst du noch einen anderen? Auch Walzer nicht.
Ich kann nur Techno -Gehobse, das andere hab ich nicht gelernt.
Und dann gibt's auch die Opernball -Demo, ungleich mehr Leute, mit besseren Kostümen.
Ja auf jeden Fall bunter. Ja, auch mit schöner Polizeibegleitung. Meistens ist es kalt.
Pferde? Pferde haben sie dabei?
Nein, Pferdestaffel haben wir nicht.
Habt ihr keine Pferdestaffel?
Nein, das wollte die FPÖ anschaffen und das hat aber dann Ibiza verhindert.
Wien wird mir immer sympathischer.
Hätten wir nicht erfolgreich gewesen, hätten wir jetzt Pferde auf der Opernballdemo.
Guck mal, in Wien kannst du demonstrieren, ohne dass die früher später mit Pferden in dich reinreiten.
Ibiza hat Pferde verhindert?
Kann man sagen, ja.
Pferde in Polizistenhand, also Hunde, okay.
Pferde, war ich immer skeptisch. Pferde, lasst die armen Tiere in Ruhe Leute, ehrlich.
Lasst die Tiere in Ruhe. Nee wirklich, finde ich nicht in Ordnung.
Auf jeden Fall dürfen wir die Sendung nicht so sehr in die Länge ziehen,
weil sonst laufen wir dann irgendwann in den Karneval rein, in den Fast,
noch haben wir natürlich viel Zeit, ist ja noch 24 Stunden hin, ne?
Ja, noch sind wir dem 9. näher als dem 11.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, ich dachte nur ich spreche das mal an, weil das ist ja.
Nach zwölf Jahren irgendwie keine Idee mehr gehabt, wie du mir noch einen auswischen kannst.
Also ich meine, mit dem Karneval, also ich akzeptiere, bevor jetzt,
jetzt müssen wir uns ja wieder auf Feedback einstellen, was Karneval betrifft.
Oder Jerken und den Narren kommen jetzt.
Ja, da gibt's ja so die, ich kenn ja auch ein paar Konvertierte,
ich kenn auch so ein paar aus dem Westen, die dann, entschuldigung aus dem Osten,
die dann mal rüber gemacht haben im Westen und dem dann auch was abgewonnen haben.
Aber so richtig mit hier in so einen Narrenclub reingehen und Büttenräder halten
und das volle Programm und dann wahrscheinlich, keine Ahnung,
man hört ja so Sachen, was dann auch so gemacht wird, auf der Straße auch.
Und auch außerhalb der Straße. Da wird überall hingepisst.
Und du erinnerst dich, eine der besten Büttenreden hat ja, wie heißt die ehemalige
Düsseldorfer, die war nicht Bürgermeisterin, aber stellvertretende glaube ich, Verteidigung,
Margrethe Strack -Zimmermann.
Die ist gut.
Die hat eine Büttenrede gehalten. Über den Flugzwerg.
Eine der bekanntesten Büttenreden überhaupt, also die hat das Genre neu definiert,
als sie eine Büttenrede über Friedrich Merz gehalten hat, während der da saß.
Ich kann mich nicht mehr daran erinnern, dass das stattgefunden hat.
Das hat gesessen.
Flugzwerg.
Ja, die hatte sehr, das war gut. Und der hatte sich auch nachher darüber beklagt,
was auch einfach, ich mein das ist einfach so.
Die Lady ist sowieso scharf, also die ist scharf im Hirn, die ist wirklich,
also man glaubt gar nicht, dass sie bei der FPP ist.
Ich hab mal mit der in die CE gesessen, die haben nicht getraut irgendwas zu
sagen, ich dachte die macht sofort einen kurzen Prozess. Ich mach die Sicherheit.
Ja bitte. Nee, aber diese Rede war großartig und der Kardinalsfehler ist,
ich meine daran heißt es auch wirklich, dass du ein schlechter Mensch bist,
wenn du beim Karneval nicht mitlachst.
Das ist so richtig, da bist du ganz unten.
Wenn man da nicht mit lacht.
Ja vor allem wenn es um einen selber geht. Da bist du ganz oben.
Achso ja klar.
Kannste nicht machen.
Also ich bin immer bereit mitzulachen, vorausgesetzt es ist auch lustig.
Und da bin ich allerdings auch wirklich, da kann ich wirklich zickig sein.
Also ich nehm jetzt nicht alles so einfach an.
Du bist ja auch kein Karnevalist.
Du meinst ein Karnevalist lacht selbst wenn es nicht lustig ist?
Ja du kannst dich immer noch daran erfreuen, dass der andere nicht kann.
Dann sagst du halt lebst du musst noch üben.
Achso nicht fremd schämen, sondern was ist das dann so?
Konterlachen.
Konterlachen?
Das machen wir ja hier auch schon.
Konterlachen können wir. Wir stehen morgens auf und lachen erstmal einen Konter.
Wann ist denn der Opernball?
Thomas.
Jetzt fragst du mich wieder. Bald glaube ich.
Also ist das dann auch wirklich, also hat das was damit zu tun?
Nein, nicht mit Karneval, aber mit.
Man weiß das nie so genau.
Der ist am 16. Februar, also eigentlich erst wieder nächstes Jahr.
Okay, dann ist es doch eher der Abschluss, jetzt werden mich auch wieder in
den Kommentaren Leute korrigieren.
Aber ich habe mich zu erinnern, dass er letztes Jahr das erste Mal wieder war.
Okay, also es hat irgendwas mit Politik zu tun, lese ich hier gerade.
Ja, es ist halt so ein Staatsereignis, weißt du, ihr kleines Land,
Minderwertigkeitskomplex.
Du nutzt jede Chance, um dich darzustellen. Und wenn du das mit irgendwie anschlussfähig
an die gute alte Kaiserzeit tun kannst, dann freut das die Leute. Genau, 8.
Februar 2024 ist er, aber jetzt beginnen die ganzen Bälle so irgendwie rund
um die Dezemberzeit und dann aber nächstes Jahr ist der Großteil davon, jänner Februar,
also die kalte Zeit und dann geht man rein und tanzt und feiert groß, ähm, ja.
Jedenfalls Karneval, also ich hab, muss tatsächlich sagen, also ich habe mehrere
Rosenmontagszüge in Köln und Düsseldorf besucht.
Mhm.
Jedes Mal eigentlich ein Desaster.
Kultureller Tiefpunkt eigentlich. Aber es gibt in Köln die Stunksitzung.
Stunk?
Stunksitzung. Normalerweise macht man ja Prunksitzungen, da gibt's ja den Älverrat,
das ist auch das, wo die dann diese Dinger in Reimform vortragen,
die Blüten reden und dann kommt immer tata tata tata.
Und dann gibt es die Stunksitzung, das ist ein anarchisches,
sehr stark politisches Kabarett und das ist wirklich von der feinsten Sorte,
das kann man sich angucken.
Kann man allerdings nicht, weil da eigentlich unmöglich ist ein Ticket zu kriegen
oder aber sehr schwierig ist ein Ticket zu kriegen. Aber Schlugsitzungen kannst du machen.
Im E -Werk war das früher. Ich weiß nicht, ob das da immer noch ist. Da konntest du hin.
Da kamen dann auch Leute wie Gabi Köster oder wie heißt denn der eine, der...
In der Wikipedia heißt es, das wird im Fernsehen übertragen.
Das wird im Fernsehen übertragen, WDR natürlich. Das ist der höchste Punkt des Jahres.
Schlugsitzungen auf jeden Fall, klar. Eine davon. Die wird glaube ich den ganzen
Februar oder sowas aufgeführt.
Kürbis Underground ist da die Band, die da spielt, das ist ein großes Thema.
Der WDR übte mehrfach Selbstzensur, indem er bei Fernsehübertragung der Stunksitzung
bestimmte Inhalte nicht gesendet hat.
Da weißt du, dass du das richtige Programm eingeschaltet hast,
also zumindest die richtige Übertragung. Ja, ja, die haben gut.
Sehr bissiges, rein politisches Kabarett.
Und, ähm, ne das ist in Ordnung.
Okay, na gut, also wir müssen das ja auch nicht weiter vertiefen,
ich gebe einfach zu, ich hab an Karneval bisher noch nicht teilgenommen,
hatte es auch bisher nicht vor, sollte es mal passieren, müsste mir… Noch eine
Niedertage Union und du wärst Rosemutters Sohn.
Ja ne, also ich meine, ich glaube ja, oder sagen wir mal so, ich…,
Also ich bin mir sicher, dass auch hier es natürlich so ein öffentliches Bild
gibt, was man so primär wahrnimmt, wo man sich dann immer erstmal denkt,
oh mein Gott, damit will ich nichts zu tun haben.
Wie das ja so bei fast allem ist, so Hacker und Fußball und so weiter,
da gibt's immer so Leute, die stehen so draußen und dann so,
oh nee, das geht ja gar nicht.
Also ich muss dir vorsichtig sagen Tim, ich glaube der Ruf vom Fußballstadion
ist nicht ganz so gut wie der vom Karneval.
Der Ruf im Fußball ist nicht ganz so gut. Das kommt drauf an,
ich meine wenn du in Berlin rumfragst, da sieht das glaube ich ein bisschen anders aus.
Worauf ich ja eigentlich hinaus wollte ist, mir ist schon klar,
dass so eine tief verwurzelte kulturelle Tradition auch mit Sicherheit seine
absoluten Top -Spitzen hat.
Also da gibt's bestimmt richtig tolle Sachen, wo man dran teilnehmen kann,
aber man muss halt, man muss halt sozusagen, man muss halt die Stehplätze finden.
Du brauchst einen Stiefel. Aber guck mal das Logo von der Sturmsetzung,
jetzt hab ich als Pin. Das ist geil, ne? Das ist ein geiles Logo.
Du bist ja im Prinzip, bist ja Karnevalist.
Nein, das ist ja alternativer Karneval.
Wenn du alternativer Karnevalist bist, bist du ja auch Karnevalist.
Das ist ja das Ding, also man versucht da so eine Antikultur aufzumachen,
aber im Prinzip macht man sich ja mit dem dann eins. Ja natürlich.
Das ist wie Fuck Parade, da wird dann auch nur getanzt.
War auch eine große Enttäuschung oder was?
Ach die Fuck Parade hat uns tolle Sachen gebracht.
Nur nicht das was drauf stand.
Unter anderem den Techno Viking.
Eines der tollsten Memer und
leider jemand, der sein Mem nicht akzeptiert hat, der sein Mem nicht mag.
Ich hab den sogar gesehen auf dieser Veranstaltung, ich war da.
Ich hab zwar nicht die Szene, die dann so berühmt geworden ist gesehen,
aber ich hab den Typen gesehen.
Kann man den noch verlinken oder der kommt wahrscheinlich in die Teufelsküche.
Ach das ganze Netz ist voll mit Techno -Viking.
Nee, nee, der hat sich sehr viel Mühe gegeben da alles wegzuklagen, die Doku und so weiter.
Aber wenn du nach Techno Viking suchst, das Netz platzt vor Techno Viking.
Das war unmöglich und dadurch, dass er sich dann noch gewährt hat,
ist es natürlich noch schlimmer. Also wer nicht weiß, wer der Techno -Viking
ist, der hat kein Internet.
Ihr gebt einfach Techno -Viking ein.
Techno -Viking ist großartig, es gibt eine fantastische Doku dazu,
die findet man auch, wenn man richtig sucht.
Der kann besser tanzen als Tim.
Noch besser, musst du sagen. Noch besser tanzen als Tim, genau.
Ja nee, das hat auf jeden Fall schon eine bestimmte Präsenz.
Das wäre so der richtige Türsteher gewesen für unsere nächste Live -Veranstaltung.
Ich glaub nicht, dass der stillstehen könnte.
Der muss ja nicht stillstehen, der muss ja nur an der Tür stehen.
Was Türsteher halt so machen.
Ja, aber das ist halt schon, also stehen und so.
Anyway, wollen wir zum Inhalt der Sendung kommen?
Wir fangen mit Feedback an. Also ich muss ja sagen, das Feedback bei Logbuch
Netzpolitik in den letzten Monaten ist eine,
fast gesagt eine Geschichte voller Missverständnisse, nein, ist eine Erfolgsgeschichte,
weil es gibt immer mehr davon und es befruchtet sich gegenseitig und ich weiß
gar nicht wo das alles enden soll, aber wir gehen trotzdem mal auf ein paar Sachen ein.
Anfang, Anfangs, anfängt es mit, meine Sprache, wo ist sie hin?
Wir beginnen mit Ä.
Christian schreibt nämlich, Tim, kurzes Feedback zu deinen Experimenten,
die Podcastfolge durch AI von Äs und so weiter bereinigen zu lassen.
In dieser Folge ist mir das zum Teil negativ aufgefallen, beziehungsweise ich
glaube zu hören, dass da rumgeschnibbelt wurde. Von Linus wurden Worte oder
Fragmente komplett verschluckt und ich fand es teilweise unschön,
wie sich euer Sprachrhythmus, an den ich gewöhnt bin, verändert hat.
Alles etwas stressiger, weil weniger Pausen im Sprachfluss bleiben.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen, richtig so und ich hab das auch dann kurz nach Veröffentlichung
auch schon wieder korrigiert, weil es war dann ein bisschen zu viel des Guten.
Ich werde das nochmal weiter beobachten, das ist einfach mit so langen Podcasts, man müsste im Prinzip,
man braucht das interaktiv, weil das war ja so dieser Filter,
mach alles weg, was bei drei nicht auf den Bäumen ist und dann wird halt schon
sehr viel vom Flow rausgemacht und so.
Jetzt gibt es erstmal wieder alles handeditiert.
Ich kann euch sagen, das ist auch Arbeit, weil ich muss ja dann immer...
Das hört ihr ja nicht, aber der Dinos unterbricht mich ja immer und dann muss
ich das immer verschieben.
Und so.
Kommst du nämlich am Ende nach dem Schnitt viel besser rüber.
Als eigentlich. So bin ich zu dir.
Das hab ich schon öfter gehört.
Ja, jetzt weißt du auch warum. Weil ich das mit meinem Editing -Künsten sozusagen vervorbringe.
Nächster Kommentar, nein, nächste Kommentar -Kette widmet sich ausführlich und
großartig dem Thema KI -Regelung und ich dachte mir so, oh Mann,
ein Kommentar besser als der nächste.
Hier geben sich nämlich der kluge Hans, Manuel, Charlie4711 und ein weiteres
Mal der kluge Hans, die Klinke in die Hand und führen da eine sehr schöne Debatte
und die würde ich jetzt ja eigentlich gerne wiedergeben, aber ist mir zu lang.
Und deswegen habe ich Chat -GPT gebeten, mir diese Kommentare zusammenzufassen
und die wesentlichen Punkte stichwortartig aufzuschreiben.
Das heißt, dass unsere Hörer durch KI ersetzt.
Man muss mit der Zeit gehen.
Auch euch? Dann werden nicht nur wir ersetzt.
Weiß ja, wer nicht mit der Zeit geht, der geht mit der Zeit.
Dieb.
Diebere, oder? Die ich mir auch gerade noch vorschlagen lassen.
Coole Sprüche, die man im Podcast machen kann.
Der kluge Hans schreibt, Hauptargument befürwortet eine differenzierte Betrachtung
von KI -Regelierung statt eines generellen Verbots. betont die Notwendigkeit
KI in sensiblen Bereichen wie der Medizin verantwortungsvoll einzusetzen und
Missbrauch zu verhindern.
Beispiel Verwendung medizinischer Daten zu kommerziellen Zwecken.
Hat er kritisiert.
Verlangt bedächtigen Fortschritt mit Risikoabwägung und Einbeziehung gesellschaftlicher
Auswirkungen, verweist auf Forderung nach einem Moratorium in den USA und auf
das Beispiel von Google Glass.
Bildung unterstreicht die Wichtigkeit von Medienkompetenz. Soviel vom klugen
Hans, dann haben wir noch Manuel,
der fragt, erkundigt sich nach der konkreten Umsetzung von KI -Regulierung und
berücksichtigt dabei individuelle Entwicklungen von KI -Systemen auf privaten Rechnern?
Ich weiß nicht, ob diese Zusammenfassung viel Sinn macht, aber ich gebe das jetzt so wieder.
Ich werde mich ja jetzt hier nicht messen mit der künstlichen Intelligenz, weil was weiß ich schon.
Charlie, Vorschlag Doppelpunkt. Befürwortet Regulierung die bestimmte Anwendung
von KI wie in Versicherungsentscheidungen einschränken.
Warum eigentlich? Das verstehe ich nicht.
Was verstehst du nicht?
Ja, Versicherungen. Wenn die Versicherung
jetzt irgendwie risikobasiert entscheidet, das war Versicherung E.
Ich fasse ja nur zusammen, was mir hier zusammengefasst wurde.
Charlie problematisiert KI -Systeme, die unbewusst diskriminierende Entscheidungen treffen können.
Diskutiert die Relevanz von gesellschaftlichen Werten und Gerechtigkeitsprinzipien
in Bezug auf KI -Anwendungen.
Forderung, KI sollte aus kritischen Entscheidungsprozessen herausgehalten werden,
bis sie transparent und nachvollziehbar handeln können. Dann nochmal der kluge Hans.
Vielleicht auch dann noch, wenn ich jetzt kritische Entscheidungsprozesse vielleicht…,
Kluge Hans fordert Verantwortungszuschreibung für KI -Entwicklung hinsichtlich
der gesellschaftlichen Konsequenzen ihrer Produkte.
Beispiele erwähnt die Notwendigkeit von Lösungen für Probleme wie KI -generierte
Fake -Videos. Kritik, Doppelpunkt, an Selbstregelungen im KI -Bereich und verweist
auf potenzielle Gefahren für unerfahrene Nutzer.
Wunsch eine tiefgreifende Auseinandersetzung mit den Auswirkungen von KI auf die Gesellschaft.
Diesem Wunsch schließen wir uns an.
Also Tim ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt so, also das hat sonst mehr Spaß gemacht.
Ja ne. Man muss es ja mal probieren.
Ja. Aber so Karneval Stimmung kommt da jetzt nicht auf.
Ja das stimmt. Wir empfehlen euch den Konsum der Kommentarspalte.
Deswegen sind die auch alle verlinkt.
Dazu gibt es dann auch gleich noch den passenden Kommentar den ich nicht von
JGPT zusammenfassen lasse.
Logbuch Netzpolitik ist der einzige Podcast bei dem ich die Kommentarspalte
immer mit großem Vergnügen lese und dann sehr gerne eure Diskussion in der Kommentarspalte
in der nächsten Ausgabe anhöre und dann wiederum mit Interesse die Kommentare
über die Diskussion lese.
Danke. Gerade bei einem so großen Thema wie KI bereichern und sinnig. Stimmt. Das ist wahr.
Das geht mir mittlerweile auch so. Das ist gut.
Auch wenn jetzt mein Zusammenfassungsversuch so ein bisschen gescheitert ist.
Das ist nicht deiner Tim, das war ein Large Language Model.
Jaja, aber ich hab's ja initiiert, ich bin ja Owner dieses Konzepts.
So nennt man das glaube ich.
Du bist der Promptingenieur, du hast dir die Kommentare da reingekopypastet.
Ja also dem Ingenieur, naja.
So dann haben wir über Zeitreisen fabuliert und getestet ob die funktionieren
und festgestellt, dass sie nicht gehen.
Daraufhin merkt an fckgw. Thema Zeitreise und warum niemand aus der Zukunft
ein Zeichen gesendet hat. Hier sehe ich die folgenden Möglichkeiten.
Erstens, also sagen wir mal A. In 500 Jahren hört niemand den Podcast und Zeitreise
wurde nicht erfunden. B.
In 500 Jahren hört niemand den Podcast und Zeitreise wurde erfunden.
C. In 500 Jahren hört jemand den Podcast und Zeitreise wurde nicht erfunden.
D. In 500 Jahren hört jemand den Podcast und Zeitreise wurde erfunden.
Für den letzten Fall und das ist,
IMHO, das heißt in meiner Meinung nach, der einzige den es hierbei zu betrachten
lohnt, stellt sich die Frage, also in 500 Jahren hört jemand den Podcast und
Zeitreise wurde erfunden, der wird jetzt betrachtet.
Da stellt sich die Frage, warum sollte jemand die Technik der Zeitreise nutzen,
um zwei Leuten, die gerade einen Podcast aufzeichnen, ein Zeichen zu senden?
Sollte sich zu diesem Zeitpunkt die Menschheit in einer...
Das ist so ein überheblicher Zeitreisender. Der ist extra zurückgereist,
nur um zu kommentieren, hör mal, ich kann Zeitreisen.
Du meinst doch nicht, dass ich das mach, um euch Wichten ein Zeichen zu setzen.
Das ist einer. Das ist ein Zeitreisender.
Diese Überheblichkeit verrät ihn.
Und damit wäre sein eigenes Argument schon gestorben. Aber hören wir nochmal
an, wie die Argumentation lautet.
Also sollte sich zu diesem Zeitpunkt die Menschheit in einer Utopie befinden,
würde wohl niemand diese gefährden
wollen, nur um in einem 500 Jahre alten Podcast genannt zu werden.
Okay, die Gefahr die Vergangenheit zu beeinflussen ist wohl zu groß. Good point.
Sollte sich zu diesem Zeitpunkt die Menschheit nicht in einer Utopie befinden,
was ich für wahrscheinliche Erhaltung meine ich zu sagen, haben die Leute wohl andere Sorgen,
als in einem 500 Jahre alten Podcast genannt zu werden und befürchten durch
einen Eingriff in die Vergangenheit alles nur noch schlimmer zu machen.
Könnte ja auch sein, dass auch alles besser wird durch die Zeit.
Wir haben doch alle zurück in die Zukunft und Terminator gesehen.
Und was ist die Lehre da draus?
Versuch macht klug.
Naja gut also, ich finde also wenn die Menschheit sowieso nicht in der Utopie
ist, was kann denn da jetzt noch groß passieren?
Achso ja das sag ich ehrlich gesagt auch seit ungefähr Anfang 2020.
Schlimmer kann eigentlich, also eigentlich kann ich nicht mehr schlimmer kommen,
was soll schon schief gehen?
Also ich finde, was heißt denn überhaupt 500 Jahre alte Podcast,
der ist ja immer noch frisch.
Glaubt doch nicht, dass in 500 Jahren die Diskussion um Karneval schon abgeschlossen ist.
Ich finde übrigens, ich hab gerade die Links rausgesucht zu den Kommentaren
und da ist eine Menge verloren gegangen.
Also was du hier gemacht hast, ist ja die Zusammenfassung nach Argumenten,
da steht ja auch immer Forderung, Beispiel, Kritik, Wunsch.
Soll ich es doch noch vorlesen?
Nee, der richtige, also es gibt einen schönen Kommentar vom klugen Hans.
Warte mal, Sekunde, ich muss jetzt mal kurz das mit der Zeitreise ablesen.
Achso, ich dachte wir hätten schon wieder weitergefasst.
Wie auch immer, würde jemand den Podcast hören und sich denken,
jo, da kann ich ja mal drauf reagieren und denen ein Zeichen senden,
dann müsste diese Person das ja schon im Podcast hören, weil das Zeichen ja
schon aufgezeichnet wurde, noch bevor es in der Zukunft abgesendet wurde.
Nein.
Temporale Paradoxie. Eigentlich ganz einfach.
Wie auch immer, würde jemand den Podcast hören, also in 500 Jahren,
und sich denken, da kann ich ja mal drauf reagieren und denen ein Zeichen senden,
dann müsste diese Person das ja schon im Podcast hören, weil das Zeichen ja
schon aufgezeichnet wurde, noch bevor es in die Zukunft abgesendet wird.
Das war ja eigentlich unser Test.
Wir haben ja kurz gewartet, es hat nichts passiert.
Also temporale Paradoxie, das können wir auch.
Ja das stimmt, aber es ist schon klar Leute, da sind wir auch auf euch angewiesen,
dass ihr euren Kindern auch immer sagt, in LMP 474 haben Tim und Linus sich
ein Zeichen gewünscht. Also anders funktioniert das nicht.
Und das habt ihr nicht gemacht und deswegen hat es nicht funktioniert.
Vielleicht hat's auch funktioniert, wir haben das Zeichen nicht wahrgenommen.
Ich fand sehr schön den Kommentar vom klugen Hans, der hat einfach einen Wunsch,
den ich auch hege, der ist einfach druckreif,
ich würde eine Herangehensweise begrüßen, in der nicht ich die Konsequenzen
von Problemen beantworten muss, die jemand anderes in die Welt gesetzt hat.
Das ist so ne, also damit kann ich mich identifizieren.
Das wäre schon okay.
Das ist das Gegenteil von meinem Job.
Ja, von meinem auch.
Okay, also ich entschuldige mich für die schlechte Zusammenfassung eurer Kommentare.
Du musst dich dafür entschuldigen, dass du das einer KI überlassen hast.
Ja, das ist ja eigentlich das gleiche. Ich owne das ja auch.
Ich owne ja mein Handeln.
Ich bin ja handlungsfähig. Ich bin ja sozusagen auch entscheidend.
Das ist ja nur ein Werkzeug.
Ich kann ja nicht dem Hammer die Schuld geben, dass er auf deinen kleinen Finger gelandet ist. Ja.
Das hab ich schon selber verkackt.
Okay.
So, dann noch ein Kommentar mit Besserwisserei.
Hat Shachipiti so gesagt.
Nee, J .D. hat gesagt, Tim kann sich vermutlich an die Olympischen Spiele in
China erinnern und nicht an die Olympiade.
Boah,
das ist auch so ein Silvester -Silvester -Korrigierer.
Eine Olympiade bezeichnet die vier Jahre zwischen den Spielen.
Und was ist, wenn mal Spiele ausfallen, weil die Nazis wieder an die Macht gekommen sind?
Aber hier scheiße es noch, wobei wohl schon die Griechen den Begriff falsch verwendet haben.
Vor 500 Jahren?
Ja, eben.
Da hast du das ja gehört.
Darauf reagiere ich ja nur.
Ich war jetzt gerade mal zwei Wochen bei der ersten Olympiade, war ganz geil.
Timotheos Pretlavos.
Ich habe gewonnen, Marathon habe ich gewonnen.
Wo?
Na wo?
Vor 500 Jahren?
Olympia, wo sonst?
Ich dachte der wäre nach Marathon gewonnen.
Ja, aber die Olympia, also die olympischen Spiele waren ja ein... Olympia.
Schon die alten Griechen haben den Begriff falsch verwendet.
Vor wieviel hundert Jahren haben die das falsch gemacht? Da kannst du immer
noch ein Deutsch sagen. Falsch.
Ich liebe diese Leute. Es ist falsch.
Das ist super. Ich meine wenn man sich noch nicht mal mehr auf die Griechen
verlassen kann, dann ist ja einfach, ich brauche mal mit Logik gar nicht mehr zu kommen.
Ich möchte aber noch was kluges kluges sagen.
Die ganze Olympiade hat auch in China stattgefunden.
Hat sie.
Aber die kann doch gar nicht stattfinden, wenn es die Zeit dazwischen ist.
Möchtest du denen die vier Jahre etwa absprechen? Ich bin mir relativ sicher,
dass es ausführliche Dokumentationen über diese Olympiade gibt.
Ist die Olympiade nicht überall?
Sie ist überall und immer.
Und sie ist höher, weiter und schneller, als wir sie uns überhaupt vorstellen.
Wer von uns beiden ist heute der Jack, wer ist der Narre? Der Narre.
Weiß nicht, wer ist denn schlimmer?
Naja, die ist...
Ich werde mich jetzt nicht, also ich habe gesagt wir äußern uns nicht zum Israel
-Palästina -Konflikt und ich werde jetzt nicht irgendwie zwischen Köln und Düsseldorf
eine Entscheidung treffen. Das mache ich nicht.
Ja, da ist was dran.
Aber jetzt können wir anfangen, oder?
EIDAS.
Jetzt fangen wir an.
Jo. Ich wollte ein bisschen was erzählen über die...
Nein, wolltest du nicht. Wir haben gesagt, dass du das machen musst.
Du kannst nicht ehrlich sein. Thomas hat keinen Bock drauf.
Ich hatte ja eh nichts vor. Ne, es gibt auch was zu berichten,
denn es ist endlich vorbei.
Nach über zwei Jahren haben wir diese große Reform auf EU -Ebene abgeschlossen
zu EIDAS, zu digitaler Identität und darüber wollten wir kurz reden.
Wofür steht das AIS?
Identity and Trust Services. Niemand weiß wirklich wofür ich das steht.
Das ist ein ganz altes Gesetz.
Electronic Identification, Authentication and Trust Services.
Exactly. Aber das ist auch alles 2014 ursprünglich schon mal beschlossen worden
und dann piggybacked auf diese alte Verordnung, dieses neue Ding,
was so bestehende staatliche Identitätssysteme auch ersetzen soll mittelfristig.
Also was in Deutschland zum Beispiel der Personalausweis ist mit digitaler Funktion
oder in Österreich die ID Austria.
Eigentlich gibt es in jedem EU -Land so ein solches System.
Teilweise eben noch kartenbasiert, manchmal schon als Smartphone,
manchmal mit Hardware -Sicherheitsschlüssel, manchmal nur webbasiert.
Und all das wird jetzt eben ergänzt um ein Smartphone -basiertes System.
Also die Idee ist, dass nach dieser Reform es eine European Digital Identity Wallet geben soll.
Wir nennen sie einfach jetzt mal die Wallet, der Einfachheit halber.
Und das ist so eine App auf dem Smartphone, die die Staaten herausgeben sollen.
Und über die kann man sich dann eben rechtsverbindlich ausweisen gegenüber dem
Staat, aber auch gegenüber der Privatwirtschaft.
Man kann auch Attribute da drin haben, die teils vom Staat kommen können,
wie die Identität, der Führerschein, aber auch zum Beispiel Diploma von Universitäten.
Es können da auch Gesundheitsdaten abgelegt werden, wie zum Beispiel so ein
Corona -Impf -Zertifikat.
Und diese Attribute können aber auch rein nur von der Privatwirtschaft kommen,
wie zum Beispiel irgendwelche Kundenkarten.
Zum Beispiel auch Zugtickets, ÖPNV soll darüber abgewickelt werden,
aber vielleicht auch ein Schufa -Score oder ein anderer Bonitäts -Score.
Das klingt jetzt erstmal nicht falsch.
Gleichzeitig wenn ich, also technisch, alles was du jetzt sagst klingt für mich
eigentlich wie so ein bisschen,
wir machen mal so ein NFC Standard im Smartphone, weil das ist ja das wie derartiges
heutzutage im besten Falle abgebildet wird, über NFC.
Also Kreditkarten machen NFC, einen Ausweis könntest du NFC sprechen lassen,
alles was nicht fälschbare, digitale Dinge sein sollen machst du eigentlich
mit NFC, was letztendlich, wenn ich das übersetze auch nur quasi das ist, was vorher Smartcard,
ein Smartcard Protokoll mit über die Luft statt über Kupfer.
Und vor allem was, du hast App gesagt, also wenn ich App höre und dann sowas
wie wichtiger Ausweise, Identität etc.
Das hat einfach gar nicht mehr in die App zu kommen, sondern das hat einfach
im Kern des Betriebssystems mit entsprechenden sicheren Hardware Schutzkammern im Prozessor gemacht.
Und die sind nix anderes als eine fest verlötete Smartcard. Also du kannst heute
eine eSIM haben weil du eine.
Worauf ich hinaus will ist, es wäre sinnvoll hier von vornherein einen Standard
zu schaffen, den alle Smartphone Hersteller schon auf Betriebssystem Ebene umsetzen.
Auf Hardware Ebene.
Und damit halt auch auf Hardware -Ebene und dann kümmert sich quasi das Betriebssystem
darum, weil wenn du erstmal mit anfängst mit so einer App, dann landest du halt
bei so einem Quatsch wie Ausweis App 2.
Aber darf ich dazu ganz kurz einen Initial -Rant machen, Thomas?
Also, es gab ja jetzt neue iPhones.
Und ich habe eins gekauft. Und ich habe einen schwerwiegenden Schmerz erleben
müssen beim Umzug der ganzen zwei Faktor -Apps auf,
also da gibt's ja auch einen, Der Initialrant zu diesem Initialrant ist ja eigentlich
nach der Einführung der PCSD2,
nee Quatsch, war das, ne?
PSCD, PCSD ist der PC Smartcard, den man braucht um die Dinger auszulesen,
ein anderes Thema, okay, aber die Die PST2,
da gab's ja den Initialrant übrigens in der Volksbühne am Rosa Luxemburg Platz,
da hat sich nichts dran geändert, es ist eine absolute Katastrophe,
mit diesen zwei Faktor -Apps, dann hast du ein neues Telefon und willst du umziehen,
dann zieht das alles nicht mit um.
Und weißt du, was passiert, wenn du so ein neues, das alte iPhone,
neues iPhone, sagt der hier sollen wir scannen, du scannst den Code und dann
sagt das alte iPhone, ja, jetzt ist alles drüber, sollen wir mal löschen und
dann haben die halt einen riesigen Löschbutton und ich so, ne ne ne,
hier wird nichts gelöscht,
hier wird nichts gelöscht, da hab ich gesagt weitermachen.
Und dann war alles umgezogen, außer sämtliche zweite Faktoren,
die irgendwie im Google Authenticator waren und sämtliche,
weißte, Secure hast du nicht gesehen, Schnäpp, Drep, warste da alles irgendwie
und hier ist QR -Tan plus und was nicht alles, alles im Arsch.
Ich wäre pleite gewesen, es wäre alles vorbei gewesen, wenn ich dieses iPhone
gelöscht hätte, hätte ich wieder von vorne anfangen müssen Geld zu verdienen. Und dann...
Musst du durch diese ganzen Tänze aufführen, um diese neuen Telefone zu registrieren.
Und mein altes Telefon habe ich einem Familienmitglied übergeben,
wo ich dann diese Tänze nochmal machen musste, das heißt ich hab jetzt irgendwie
eine Reihe an Banking -Zwei -Faktor -Apps durch Und in diesem Prozess von sagen wir mal ungefähr 5, 6,
7 so Dinger umziehen, hab ich 2 gekillt.
Ja, das dann irgendwie so, also 3 mal irgendwas falsch eingegeben,
irgendwas falsch gemacht, wuppdi bupp, hier drücken, links, A,
K, D, und dann so, jetzt fahren Sie bitte zur Bank oder jetzt kriegen Sie einen Aktivierungsbrief.
Und dann müssen Sie mit dem alten Handy den Brief und neu und hier und bloß nicht den.
Dann nochmal hier das IQR -Code scannen und da an die Kamera halten und dann
hast du das aber auf deinem Bildschirm, auf deinem Wechsler. Es war zu heulen.
Wir haben da eben gesessen und gesagt so, ah shit, tot. Wie viel Geld ist jetzt
weg? Ja, war nicht so schlimm.
500 Euro. Okay, tragisch. Aber eine Katastrophe und deswegen bräuchte man dafür
einen Standard, der das potenziell stabil hinkriegt.
Nicht nur potenziell stabil, der das einfach total krass mega stabil hinbekommt
und wo solche Probleme von vorne,
ich meine was du da beschreibst, ich meine ich sehe jetzt wirklich vor meinem
geistigen Auge so tausende Anhörerinnen und Hörer, die alle da so sitzen und sich denken so,
ja das war so scheiße, das will ich nie wieder machen, aber ich muss.
Vor allem, die Apple haben ja immer, es gab die viel gelogten Apple Human Interface
Guidelines, die als der Höhepunkt und die Bibel der User Experience gelten.
Und dass ein Knopf, ja ich möchte mein gesamtes iPhone löschen,
irgendwie riesengroß da ist und unten so, nö, nö, alle meine Daten später löschen,
das ist einfach eine Katastrophe. Okay, sorry.
Solche Rahen sind berechtigt.
Natürlich sind die berechtigte Stäbe außer Frage.
Also dieser Wallet soll übrigens auch verwendet werden können für den Login
bei allen großen Big Tech Plattformen, also alles was in der EU als Very Large
Online Plattform gilt, also Google, Apple, Facebook,
aber auch Booking .com zum Beispiel oder TikTok,
die müssen das alles anbieten als Alternative zum Passwort, um sich dort einzuloggen.
Die Banken werden sehr wahrscheinlich auch jetzt dazu gezwungen werden,
das zu verwenden, schon allein um ihre Inhaber von Bankkonten zu identifizieren.
Und noch mal zu dem Punkt des Zugriffs auf irgendwelche Hardware -Secure -Module.
Da schreibt das Gesetz auch vor, dass die Hersteller der Geräte das zulassen müssen.
Sprich, Zugriff auf die Secure Enclave, ähnlich wie Google und Apple,
den sie selbst auch geben für ihre eigenen Wallets, muss laut dem EU -Gesetz auch gewährt werden.
Und da ist die Kommission auch klar angetreten mit der Ansage,
wir wollen hier eine europäische Alternative zu einer Apple - oder Google -Wallet.
Das war nach der Pandemie 2021, als das Gesetz vorgestellt wurde,
noch so auf dieser Welle, jetzt müssen wir alles online machen,
weil die Leute sind ja noch eingesperrt.
Und man wollte hier auch ganz klar nicht die Möglichkeit schaffen,
dass jetzt ein Standard sich weltweit verbreitet, der nur von Big Tech kommt.
Das ist sicherlich auch noch ein Beispiel mit dieser ganzen Exposure -Notification
-Geschichte, also was diese ganzen Corona -Apps betrifft.
Auf jeden Fall ist das aus Datenschutzsicht natürlich ein superheitliches Gesetz,
denn wir haben hier – technisch hat DINUS recht, das ist alles jetzt nichts
Neues, was hier als Grundlage dient – aber die neue Dimension ist halt die Rechtsverbindlichkeit.
Dass es wirklich staatlich zertifizierte Identitätsinformationen sind,
dass es ein rechtlich gültiger und
verbindlicher Weg ist, um eine Lenkerberechtigung, einen Corona -Status.
Lenkerberechtigung ist ein Führerschein in Österreich, ne?
Genau, genau. Also alles, was man halt...
Da muss man nur lenken, da muss man... Das ist nicht so groß das Land.
Über Führung reden wir nicht.
Auf vielen Stellen war uns von Anfang an so klar, das Ding könnte echt in allen
möglichen Gesellschaftsfeldern Niederschlag finden und dadurch natürlich auch
einen enormen Einblick liefern in alle möglichen Alltagssituationen.
Und da ist die Gefahr, dass man überidentifiziert wird, sehr groß.
Wir haben in vergangenen Sendungen ja eh schon viel über die Probleme berichtet,
die ich hier nur zusammenfasse. Aber das war sozusagen immer die Gefahr,
die wir vor Augen hatten.
Die aber dann versucht hat, zu begegnen mit konkreten Safeguards im Gesetz.
Also welche Absicherungen können wir da einbauen, um den Schaden zu minimieren?
Und es war immer klar, verhindert kriegt man das Ding nicht.
Und wir haben jetzt eben einige Sachen, über die ich berichten will,
die dann, glaube ich, auch in der Praxis ganz relevant sind, diese Rechte zu kennen.
Das Wichtigste ist, glaube ich, dass es eine Nichtdiskriminierungsregel gibt
für alle Menschen, die dieses System nicht verwenden wollen.
Also wer jetzt sagt, ich will weiter Dinge analog machen, ich will nicht umziehen
auf dieses neue EU -System, darf in keinster Weise schlechter gestellt werden,
auch keine höheren Preise oder Gebühren bei E -Government.
Gibt es ja in vielen Ländern schon, wenn man noch Papier braucht,
zahlt man 30, 40 Prozent mehr.
Es ist auch beim Arbeitsmarkt und in der Wirtschaft so, dass man nicht schlechter
gestellt sein darf, wenn man dieses System nicht verwendet.
Und das ist ganz wichtig, weil wir sehen jetzt zum Beispiel schon mit dem European
Health Data Space, dass dieser Wallet der Dreh - und Angelpunkt sein soll beim
Arztbesuch, wenn man in die Apotheke geht,
um dort ein Medikament, das man verschrieben bekommen hat, einzulösen und so weiter.
Es ist ja auch so, dass der digitale Euro über dieses selbe Wallet funktionieren soll.
Also da kommt relativ viel sektorspezifische Gesetzgebung auf uns zu,
die auch wiederum auf diesem System basieren wird.
Und wir haben, weil das Ganze für die Wirtschaft geöffnet ist und dann eben
vielleicht auch mal der Supermarkt oder die Versicherung oder andere Firmen Dinge fragen wollen.
Da ist uns ganz wichtig, dass die Dinge, die man da fragen kann,
nicht fair game sind, sondern dass es dann Regulierung von Use Cases gibt.
Und da haben wir es geschafft, dass wirklich jede Firma, die das verwenden will,
sich anmelden muss bei dem Staat, wo auch immer sie niedergelassen ist,
mit dem konkreten Use Case für die Wallet und den Daten, die sie vom User anfragen will.
Und sie darf nicht mehr anfragen, als das, was in dieser Registrierung drin
steht. Das ist technisch verhindert.
Und die Liste der registrierten Firmen mit ihren Use Cases und den angefragten
Daten muss öffentlich sein.
Das heißt, da kann man dann auch relativ gut Kontrolle ausüben von unabhängiger
Seite, auch von Konsumentenschutzorganisationen, um zu schauen,
ob es hier irgendwo Missstand gibt.
Wer sich erinnert, wir haben auch lange darüber geredet, dass es einen unique
persistent identifier geben soll, also so ein Personen -Kennzeichen,
das dann wirklich ein Leben lang einen Menschen eindeutig in Europa identifizieren soll.
Und das haben wir komplett gekillt. Das ist nicht mehr im Text drinnen.
Es gibt so etwas nicht mehr.
Und in Deutschland gab es ja auch das 80er -Jahre -Volkszählungsurteil,
auf das wir uns da auch berufen haben.
Das ist eben nicht so eine eindeutige Seriennummer für Menschen geben darf.
Wenn man diese Wallet verwendet, dann gibt es auch den Safeguard,
dass im ersten Schritt mal die Firma, die anfragt oder die Behörde,
sich identifizieren muss mir gegenüber.
So richtig auch mit Firmen -ID und mit Kontaktadresse und dann sehe ich,
was die von mir wissen will und ich kann natürlich alles geben,
nichts geben oder Selectively Disclosure heißt es, einzelne Datenfelder hergeben, aber andere nicht.
Du darfst wissen, dass ich einen Führerschein habe, aber eben nicht,
wo ich wohne. Meine Adresse kriegst du nicht.
Wenn man nicht identifiziert wird über diesen Use Case, dann muss die Weitergabe
von Eigenschaften über die Person unlinkable sein.
Das heißt, ich darf nicht gecheckt werden. Es darf keine Möglichkeit geben,
dass wenn ich jetzt irgendwie jeden Freitag im Berghain meinen Alternachweiser
mit dieser Wallet, dann die sehen, okay, der kommt jede Woche wieder.
Also unlinkability.
Ich glaube, wenn du dem Berghain gegenüber in der Situation bist,
dass du dein Alter nachweisen musst, dann wirst du nicht in die Situation kommen,
dass du dein Alter nachweisen musst.
Ich spreche nicht aus Erfahrung.
Doch, natürlich, du und ich damals mit 17. Nur wegen unseren Ausweisen an der Tür gescheitert.
Nur deswegen. Auf jeden Fall Anlinkability hilft halt überall da,
wo ansonsten getrackt würde.
Wo es die Möglichkeit sonst gäbe, mit irgendwelchen Identifiern Profile über
Leute zu bilden und zu wissen, dass jemand jetzt zum zweiten,
dritten Mal wiederkommt.
Sowohl aus der Perspektive von dem einen Clubbetreiber, der eine Firma,
wie auch global gesehen.
Also auch, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel die eine Firma die andere kauft und da
liegen noch die Daten rum, können die die nicht miteinander korrelieren.
Und zuletzt auch noch Zero Knowledge. Das bedeutet, ich kann Dinge über mich
beweisen, ohne die zugrunde liegenden Daten herzugeben.
Das bedeutet, ich kann nachweisen, dass ich ein gewisses Alter erreicht habe,
ohne mein Geburtsdatum herzugeben.
Wir haben vorher schon gesagt, das Ding wird auch bei Google und Apple und Facebook
zum Einsatz kommen müssen, weil das im Gesetz drin steht.
Und überall da, wo es um soziale Netzwerke geht, ist die Gefahr einer Klarnamenpflicht natürlich groß.
Und wir haben ein Recht auf Pseudonymität gemäß dem Gesetz.
Also du hast immer die Wahl, dass du frei gewählte Pseudonyme anstatt eines
Namens hergibst. Überall da, wo es keine gesetzliche Grundlage gibt, dass du dich ausweist.
Also man kann immer noch so ein Klarnamensgesetz machen. Wurde ja in Deutschland,
in Frankreich, in Österreich immer wieder mal diskutiert.
Aber ohne so ein Gesetz darf die Firma dich nicht zwingen, deine Identität herzugeben.
Wenn sie rechtliche Verpflichtungen hat, jetzt deinen Namen zu kennen,
wie eine Bank, wo du ein Konto aufmachen willst, dann natürlich schon.
Und zuletzt gibt es so ein Privacy Cockpit. Das ist eine Transaktionshistorie,
wo du genau siehst, wer hat dich was gefragt, was hast du mit denen geteilt.
Und da kannst du einerseits dann deinen Widerspruch einlegen gegen die Verarbeitung deiner Daten.
Also wirklich mit so einem Knopf sagen, hey, ich entziehe meine Einwilligung, löscht meine Daten.
Und du kannst dich auch bei der lokalen Datenschutzbehörde in deinem Land beschweren über diese Firma.
Was halt auch hilft, wenn da Schindler getrieben wird.
Das sind die guten Sachen.
Es gibt noch schlechte. Jaja, genau. Ich find das ja super.
Ich würd jetzt einmal ganz kurz die Guten zusammenhalten. Also wir haben,
dass sich diskriminiert werden, wenn du das nicht benutzt, die Use Cases sind
reguliert, aber was ich sehr spannend finde, ist kein Unique Identifier,
es gibt Selective Disclosure, Unlinkability und Zero Knowledge,
das heißt, Wenn ich jeden Tag irgendwo nachweise, beispielsweise ich bin 18,
dann verrate ich nicht mein Geburtsdatum,
ich verrate keine Personenkennziffer und auch nichts anderes,
was erlauben würde, die beiden Vorgänge miteinander zu verbinden und ich kann
auch sicherstellen, dass ich nur disclose, dass ich über 18 bin.
Also das heißt, jetzt frage ich mich, das heißt aber auch, dass es potenziell,
ich zweimal hintereinander den gleichen Ausweis zeigen kann, für den gleichen Check.
Ja, das Ding mit Zero Knowledge, Altersverifikation ist, wenn du das Geburtsdatum
nicht hast, musst du das bei jedem Schritt machen, weil es kann ja sein,
dass du ein gewisses Alter erst später überschritten hast.
Wenn du es einmal überschritten hast und es ist dann zu deinem,
weiß nicht, Instagram -Profil zum Beispiel gespeichert, dann natürlich nicht.
Du wirst nicht jünger mit der Zeit.
Aber wenn man jetzt sagt, es ist ein soziales Netzwerk, das spezifisch nur für
Kinder oder Jugendliche ist, dann müsste man das so machen, ja.
Okay, aber ich überlege gerade, ob es Situationen gäbe, wo man dann.
Also dadurch wäre der Ausweis ja vollständig von einer Identität entkoppelt,
sogar von sich selber vollständig entkoppelt.
Und wenn man drei Leute kontrollieren würde und die halten alle drei den gleichen
Ausweis hin, würde man nicht merken, dass es dreimal der gleiche war.
Das ist immer das Problem, solange du diese App nicht wirklich mit Biometrie
verknüpfst, mit der eigentlichen Person.
Und wohlgemerkt, es müssten biometrische Merkmale sein, die zentral professioniert
werden und nicht einfach Face -ID, Touch -ID vom User selbst auf dem Gerät eingetragen sind.
Ja, da kannst du mit dem Ausweis von Papa Bier kaufen gehen.
Das ist ein Szenario, was hier nicht ausgeschlossen ist, wenn du die Person nicht identifizierst.
Es ist leider nicht geglückt, dass Biometrie ausgeschlossen ist.
Das haben wir im Parlament durchbekommen, dass Biometrie keine Voraussetzung
für die Verwendung der Wallet sein darf.
Im finalen Text ist das schwammiger formuliert. Es könnte sein,
dass du diese App nur verwenden kannst, wenn du Biometrie auf deinem Gerät freigeschalten hast.
Dadurch ist natürlich eher eine Möglichkeit gegeben, dass die Person,
die es verwendet, auch die ist, wenn es gedacht ist.
Allerdings ist es ja so, dass eigentlich sämtliche Biometrie -Scanner,
die Telefone bisher haben, insbesondere wenn es dabei darum geht die Secure
Enclave oder sowas freizuschalten,
am Ende ein Fallback haben auf dem Pin.
Ja?
Auch müssen, weil vielleicht hast du eine Maske auf oder eine Augenklappe wie
der Bundeskanzler oder so.
Ist eigentlich, also in der jetzigen Implementierung ist so,
dass der Scanner in der Lage ist potenziell die Secure Enclave freizuschalten,
aber wenn das nicht funktioniert, dann gibts halt einen Pin ein.
Ja, da bin ich mir jetzt nicht sicher, wie genau das implementiert ist.
Ich glaube schon, dass es jetzt schon eher die Anwendungen gibt,
die eben nicht mit einem Pin funktionieren, sondern nur über Biometrie oder
wo zumindest die Biometrie freigeschalten sein muss dafür,
dass du das Gerät überhaupt aufsetzen kannst, also die App mit deiner Identität bespielen.
Ob dann natürlich die eingebaute Funktion, wenn die Biometrie fehlschlägt,
dir noch die Möglichkeit eines Pins anbietet, kann ich jetzt nicht beantworten.
Wir hätten gerne einen Weg gehabt, dass du immer einen Pin haben kannst als
zweiten Faktor und eben nicht zwingenderweise die Biometrie verwenden musst.
Das ist halt leider nicht durchgegangen und deswegen wird es da sicherlich auch
wieder einen großen nationalen Spielraum geben, wie genau das dann ausgestattet wird.
Aber kommen wir mal zu den wirklich schlechten Sachen. Also die eine Sache,
die uns am meisten stört, ist die Unbeobachtbarkeit.
Wer sich erinnert, wir haben das ja schon bei den Corona -Zertifikaten gehabt
und auch zu diesem Thema immer wieder dazugesagt,
so eine Plattform wird ziemlich breit
in fast allen Gesellschafts - und Lebensbereichen zur Anwendung kommen.
Zumindest ist das der Worst Case, den wir planen müssen.
Und das würde bedeuten, dass der Staat natürlich auch, wenn er die Transaktionen
einsehen kann, wer was mit wem tut, dann wäre die Möglichkeit auch gegeben,
panoptisch in jeden Lebensbereich reinzuschauen.
Wenn du zum Arzt gehst, wenn du dich bei Facebook einloggst,
wenn du die U -Bahn verwendest, wenn du mit dem Staat kommunizierst,
wenn du dich bei deiner Bank einloggst.
Und all diese Interaktionen geben ein ziemlich vollständiges Bild über das Leben eines Menschen.
Und deswegen wäre es super gut gewesen, da einfach Schranken einzuziehen,
dass der Staat, der diese App ja herausgibt, niemals sehen kann,
welche Transaktionen die User darüber tätigen, zumindest im Regelfall nicht
sehen kann. Das ist nicht durchgegangen.
Aber das braucht er doch auch überhaupt nicht.
Wieso?
Also die Daten bräuchte, ja das war immer unser Argument, die Daten braucht
man nicht, die will man nicht haben.
Und im Sinne der Datensparsamkeit wäre es sinnvoll, wenn wir die gar nicht anfallen lassen.
Die Kommission hat dann halt gesagt, ja, diese Daten gibt es,
aber die müssen logisch und physisch getrennt werden von allen anderen Daten,
was halt Strafverfolgungsbehörden nicht wirklich abhält.
Und in dem Punkt ist das Parlament leider nicht unserer Aufforderung gefolgt
und hat hier sozusagen den Willen des Rates der Mitgliedsstaaten walten lassen.
Und deswegen ist diese Unbeobachtbarkeit nicht ausgeschlossen, also nicht gegeben.
Und es wird da auch wiederum auf die technische Ausgestaltung ankommen.
Jedenfalls unschön ist die Sache mit den Quarks, mit dem Artikel 45,
wo es in letzter Zeit auch einen riesigen, großen, offenen Brief gab der Unbeobachtbarkeit
und diese Frage der HTTPS -Zertifikate zum Thema hatte.
Und dabei geht es um die Frage, wie sichern wir denn Verschlüsselung im Webbrowser ab?
Das Gesetz, um das es hier geht, das ist ja ein Gesetz, das sehr alt ist,
wo es um Vertrauensdiensteanbieter geht.
Das sind Firmen in jedem Mitgliedsstaat, die Zertifikate ausgeben.
Oft für staatliche Dienstleistungen, aber eben auch für die Privatwirtschaft.
Und die EU hat sich gedacht, es wäre doch super, wenn diese Firmen auch von
allen Browsern als vertrauenswürdige Zertifikatsautoritäten anerkannt sind.
Und haben halt übers Gesetz die Browser verpflichtet, denen zu vertauen.
Nun wissen wir aber, HTTPS und Ende -zu -Ende -Verschlüsselung im World Wide
Web haben wir aus gutem Grund.
Da war ja vor Edward Snowden, vor 2013, nicht einmal die Hälfte des Internetverkehrs verschlüsselt.
Und mit Zahlen vom letzten Jahr stehen wir bei 95 Prozent, wenn nicht schon drüber.
Also wir haben Ende -zu -Ende -Verschlüsselung heute als direkte Reaktion auf
die Massenüberwachung der NSA und da geht es ja genau darum,
dass man dem Staat nicht vertrauen kann und dass wir stattdessen eben Ende -zu
-Ende -Verschlüsselung brauchen.
Es ist aber keine, also es ist keine Ende -zu -Ende -Verschlüsselung,
wenn du zwischen Client und Server verbindest. Das ist erstmal nur Transportverschlüsselung.
Ja, ja, also es ist eine TLS, zumindest jetzt mal auf dem Transportweg, ja.
Was der Server dann damit macht, ist sicherlich noch mal, es ist ja nicht Peer
-to -Peer, es ist ja Server -Client.
Aber auf jeden Fall, die Verschlüsselung hat da ja klar geholfen,
diese Massenüberwachung zumindest schwieriger und teurer zu machen.
Und die Gefahr, die hier besteht, ist, dass, wenn der Staat sich jetzt in alle
Vertrauenslisten reinschreibt, diese Art der Überwachung und der Machine -in
-the -Middle -Überwachung vor allem wieder möglich wird.
Und es gibt da viele Staaten, die das die letzten Jahre probiert haben,
mit Druck auf Browser sich in diese Listen reinzuschummeln.
Und über dieses Thema der Quox, da geht es eigentlich darum,
dass die Identität einer Domain angegeben wird im Webbrowser,
versucht man jetzt eben, diese Zertifikatslisten aufzubrechen.
Wer in die Adresszeile seines Browsers schaut, sieht da ja ein kleines Vorhängeschloss.
Das ist für die HTTPS -Verschlüsselung.
Und wer alt ist und noch weiß, wie das vor 2009 ausgeschaut hat,
da gab es ja dann teilweise noch den Namen der Firma, die dieses Zertifikat
gekauft hat und der dieser Domain gehört.
Und Quox ist genau diese Mitte der 2000er -Idee, wieder den Firmennamen dahin zu schreiben.
Dahinter steht natürlich das Geschäftsmodell, Zertifikate zu verkaufen.
Und das wurde so als Grund vorgeschoben. Ich glaube, niemand braucht das,
um jetzt wirklich zu wissen, ob das eine Fake -Seite ist.
Es hindert einen auch niemand daran, den Namen einer Bank in Malta zu registrieren
und sich dann Zertifikate dafür zu holen.
Aber ja, also das ist gerade auch durchgekommen, also wir werden in unseren
Webbrowsern wieder in der Adresszeile irgendwelche komischen Firmennamen sehen.
Aber das ist doch nicht das Problem. Also das Problem scheint doch zu sein,
dass hier staatliche Stellen Zertifikate ausstellen dürfen und die Browser gezwungen
sind, denen zu vertrauen.
Also das eigentliche Problem ist, dass man diese, glaube ich,
unnötigen Zertifikate, also die Qualified Website Authentication,
dafür steht Quarks, also dass man wieder in der Adressleiste sieht,
wie der Beinhaber der Domain heißt,
das ist uns eigentlich egal.
Ich glaube, es bringt wenig Vorteil, aber das sollen sie ruhig machen.
Das Problem war halt wirklich, dass sie in gleichem Schritt auch noch die Ende
-zu -Ende -Verschlüsselung aufgreifen wollen.
Ich komme noch zu dem finalen Twist bei dieser Sache, da gibt es nämlich ein bisschen Hoffnung.
Aber ich gehe noch mal weiter, also ein weiteres Thema, das auch nicht gelöst ist.
Thomas, ich muss nur noch mal ganz kurz nachfragen, weil du hast das jetzt ein
bisschen high level erklärt, das ist auch super.
Heißt das, in meiner Trustchain von CA's stehen demnächst alle Staaten der Europäischen
Union verpflichtend drin?
Korrekt. Zumindest also die Vertrauensdiensteanbieter von deinem Staat.
Also wahrscheinlich die Staatsdruckerei oder wer auch immer jetzt gerade.
Was heißt denn mein Staat? Mein Browser gehört doch keinem Staat.
Das ist das Ding. Also die europäischen Browser müssen die Vertrauensdiensteanbieter
von allen EU -Staaten beinhalten in diesen Trustlists von denen Linus gerade sprach.
Ja, was ist ein europäischer Browser?
Es kann sein, dass das weltweit von den Browsern umgesetzt wird.
Wenn Sie den Browser in Europa anbieten, dann ist entweder eine eigene Version
für die UDA zum Download oder es gibt sozusagen eine weltweite Geltung davon.
Das liegt am Browser, wie Sie das umsetzen wollen.
Und es ist sogar noch ein weiteres Problem damit verknüpft, nämlich,
dass auch die Sicherheitsmaßnahmen, die ein Browser setzen kann,
um Zertifikate abzusichern, die sind jetzt auch zustimmungspflichtig durch ETSI,
durch die europäische Standardbehörde, von der man weiß, dass sie in sehr engem
Austausch mit Geheim - und Nachrichtendiensten steht.
Und das würde auch so Dinge betreffen wie Certificate Transparency,
dass man sieht, wo ein Zertifikat eingesetzt wird und von wem.
Was uns heute auch schon hilft, wenn, weiß nicht, Iran gefälschte google .com
Zertifikate ausstellt zum Beispiel.
Und da gibt es sozusagen jetzt auch, früher war es so, man hat minimale Sicherheitsanforderungen
im Gesetz und dann gibt es einen Wettbewerb nach oben hin.
Und jetzt ist es so, es gibt eine Decke, die man einzieht. Das sind die Sicherheitslevels,
Und du kannst nicht mehr darüber hinausgehen.
Und das ist natürlich genau der falsche Ansatz.
Also diese Quarks haben deswegen auch massiven Widerstand von der IT -Sicherheitscommunity ausgelöst.
Wir haben letzte Woche gemeinsam mit über 400 Forscherinnen und Forschern einen
großen Brief verschickt ans Europaparlament,
der sich genau noch mal mit Quarks und Unobservability beschäftigt und da den
Leuten ins Gewissen redet.
Und vielleicht komme ich jetzt mal dazu, was das noch bewegt hat.
Also wir haben diese Woche am Mittwoch die finale Abstimmung gehabt eigentlich,
also zumindest mal so die Einigung im Trilog zwischen Parlament, Rat und Kommission.
Und wir haben es noch mal geschafft, in den Erwägungsgründen für das Gesetz
reinzuschreiben, dass die Browser unabhängig von Quarks weiter die Freiheit haben sollen,
wie sie das am besten ausgestalten wollen, technisch oder regulatorisch die
Sicherheit und Verschlüsselung von dem World Wide Web abzusichern.
Sprich, das ist so eine Regelung, die jetzt mal, ich habe mit Mozilla geredet,
die sagen, mit dem können wir leben, das ist nicht schön, aber das gibt uns
zumindest mal die Möglichkeit, in einen Rechtsstreit zu gehen mit der EU,
mit dem guten Glauben, dass wir den wahrscheinlich gewinnen.
Wenn wir sagen, wir machen da nicht mit, ihr könnt eure Quarks haben,
aber lasst unser TLS in Ruhe, lasst unsere Transportverschlüsselung in Ruhe.
Das war wirklich ein Last -Minute -Kompromiss, der am Montag war der Text da,
Dienstag haben wir dann es geschafft, dass Zähneknirschen zugestimmt wurde und
der ist mehr oder weniger schon unter Dach und Fach.
Das bedeutet aber auch, dass es total auf den Browser drauf ankommt und bei
Mozilla kann man da vielleicht eher Hoffnung haben, bei Microsoft wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Aber ja, also bei diesem Prozess muss man auch sagen, es war super crazy,
wie das alles abgelaufen ist.
Obwohl wir eine Einigung haben, gibt es jetzt gerade auch immer noch Bewegung in ein paar Themen.
Auch bei der Unbeobachtbarkeit könnte es noch eine Veränderung auf den allerletzten Metern geben.
Wenn du sagst, wer hat eine Einigung?
Der Trilog. Das heißt, das ist das Parlament und der Rat, in dem Fall aber die
Präsidentschaft. Das ist Spanien im Moment, die wechselt ja immer,
jedes halbe Jahr, immer ein anderes Land, das dem Rat vorsitzt.
Im Moment verhandeln die Spanier mit einer Mannschaft von 20 Leuten aus dem Europaparlament.
Das sind die Abgeordneten für die Parteien mit ihren zugehörigen MitarbeiterInnen
und mit den Policy AdvisorInnen ihrer Fraktion.
Und dann ist noch irgendwie ein Team von ungefähr fünf Leuten von der Kommission
dabei. Und diese 20 Leute verhandeln das aus.
Und die sagen wir eben so, achja, so ein Browser muss uns jetzt in seinen Root
-CA -Store legen, haben wir uns überlegt.
Ja, die Idee, das alles wieder einzuführen, was 2009 von allen Browsern weltweit
rausgekickt wurde, weil es nicht funktioniert und verwirrend ist,
fand die Kommission geil, wollte sie wieder haben.
Und dass das keiner braucht, hat sie nie gekümmert.
Und dass das aber vor allem gefährlich ist für die Sicherheitsarchitektur des World Wide Webs.
Das war ihnen wahrscheinlich bewusst.
Sie haben es nie zugestanden. Es ist irgendwie ganz lustig.
Wir haben alles gehört von der Kommission, wie das ist gar kein Problem,
das ist nicht unsere Absicht. Doch genau das wollen wir.
Diese Firmen haben ja den Sicherstempel der EU. Wieso sollen diese amerikanischen
Browser jetzt irgendwie, das muss ja gut genug für die sein.
Und das war ganz oft ein Thema.
Also ich hab jetzt gerade mal gegoogelt, ich weiß nicht genau,
wie viele Root -CA's in einem Browser heute so drin sind, aber so Zahlen sind
so irgendwo zwischen 150 und 200.
Und die sind da tatsächlich vorinstalliert. Das ist also etwas weniger als es
Länder auf dieser Erde gibt, je nachdem wie man die zählt und Ähm...
Dein Browser wird erstmal grundsätzlich allen davon vertrauen.
Also wenn irgendeiner von denen sagt, der mit dem du gerade redest ist Linus
Neumann .de, dann ist das so.
Wenn die ein Zertifikat signieren, dann ist das so. Wir haben den Fall in der
letzten Sendung ja besprochen oder vorletzte Sendung mit dem Maschinenmittelangriff
auf diesen Jabba Server.
Das mussten die machen, weil sie nicht einfach ein Zertifikat ausstellen konnten.
Das war der Grund. Wenn du weißt, du hast eine CA, die in allen Browsern vorinstalliert
ist, dann kannst du einfach ein Zertifikat ausstellen und überall MITM machen.
Ja, also sehr, es ist sehr besorgniserregend, wenn Staaten sagen,
wir bringen das jetzt irgendwie mal per Gesetz durch,
dass unsere Root -CA da drin ist, gleichzeitig, also das ist sehr beunruhigend,
gleichzeitig sag ich mal ist die Situation auch heute schon relativ schlecht,
wenn man sich überlegt, was für CA's man alle im Browser hat.
Also wer seinen Browser ernst nehmen möchte, geht halt durch diesen CA -Store
und wirft alle raus, wo er, also alle Firmen, wo er potenziell oder sie keinen
Anlass sieht, denen zu vertrauen.
Und da ihr die alle nicht kennt, habt ihr wahrscheinlich auch wenig Anlass, denen zu vertrauen.
Also die Situation ist auch jetzt nicht besonders stabil und besonders sicher
oder besonders vertrauenserweckend, aber eben wenn jetzt die EU sagt,
wir wollen uns da rein verpflichten,
das ist ein beunruhigender Move,
weil natürlich Staaten das in der Vergangenheit auch ausgenutzt haben.
Und dass sie jetzt Extended Validation wieder einführen wollen,
erscheint mir neben Schauplatz, um ihre blöde eigene Zerde reinzukriegen.
Ist halt auch ein Geschäftsmodell für viele dieser Vertrauensdiensteanbieter,
diese Zertifikate zu verkaufen.
Es bringt halt nichts, aber darüber kann man streiten. Gefährlich ist es jedenfalls.
Und ich habe das auch immer wieder gesagt, wenn du mich fragst,
wem vertraue ich jetzt mehr, den Firmen, den Großen oder dem Staat? Keinem von beiden.
Es bräuchte da halt technische Lösungen mit so etwas wie Certificate Transparency,
da einfach eine Möglichkeit zu finden, dass es auffällt, wenn Schindler getrieben
wird von staatlicher Seite mit falschen Zertifikaten.
Und wer alt genug ist, erinnert sich, dass ccc .de ganz lange auch nur ein selbst
signiertes Zertifikat hatte, glaube ich auch, um so ein bisschen da ein Zeichen zu setzen.
Let's Encrypt hat das viel verändert. Dieses Projekt der IFF über das Ende -zu
-Ende -Verschlüsselung auch in die Masse kam, weil es dadurch gratis wurde.
Auf jeden Fall ist das ein wichtiger Schauplatz von dem Gesetz gewesen,
der mit dem ganzen Rest der Wallet auch nichts zu tun hatte.
Aber kommen wir zurück, was da sonst noch so unschön ist.
Ein Problem, auf das wir oft hingewiesen haben, aber das nicht gelöst ist,
ist das sogenannte Forum Shopping.
Also wenn jetzt zum Beispiel Facebook auf die Idee kommt, dass es doch super
wäre, die Leute nach ihrem Klarnamen zu fragen, weil man hat ja in den AGBs
eine Verpflichtung, sich mit Klarnamen zu identifizieren.
Und vielleicht will Facebook noch was wissen über die Leute.
Adresse, Finanzdaten, Familienstatus ist ja alles in der Wallet vorhanden.
Dann kann man sich darüber zwar beschweren, bei der lokalen Datenschutzbehörde,
aber dafür zuständig, dann Facebook Irland vielleicht rauszuwerfen aus diesem
EDAS -System, ist die irische Datenschutzbehörde.
Und damit wissen wir, das wird nicht funktionieren, weil der Job der irischen
Datenbehörde ist es, nicht unsere Daten zu schützen, sondern Facebook vor europäischen Gesetzen.
Und da ist leider überhaupt kein Bewusstsein da gewesen, gegenüber diesen großen
Firmen sinnvolle Rechtsdurchsetzungen hinzubekommen, angesichts des Problems,
dass manche Staaten halt echt ein Geschäftsmodell daraus gemacht haben,
Gesetze nicht durchzusetzen.
Was auf einer IT -Security -Perspektive problematisch ist.
Forum Shopping bezeichnet also, dass ich mir meine Jurisdiktion suchen kann
oder was genau bezeichnet der Begriff?
Genau das. Du halt einfach sagst so, hey, ich bin Glücksspielanbieter,
ich geh nach Malta, da finde ich genau das richtige Umfeld, niedrige Steuern,
da habe ich eine Aufsicht, die nimmt es nicht so genau,
da kann man Dinge vielleicht auch mal außergerichtlich regeln über andere Wege
Und da ist man sozusagen ein bisschen geschützter davor, dass die Gesetze zu
hart gegen einen angewendet werden.
Und weil das aber EU -Binnenmarkt ist, gibt es da keine Möglichkeit,
aus Deutschland oder einem anderen Staat heraus etwas dagegen zu tun,
weil allein die Aufsicht des Sitzstaates, wo die Firma niedergelassen ist,
Zuständigkeit hat zur Regulierung dieser Firma.
Und dann, das könnte dich interessieren, so diese ganze Frage,
ist das Ding am Ende sicher?
Da haben sie sich auch viele Gedanken gemacht und die Antwort ist ganz toll, wir zertifizieren das.
Es gibt Antworten für alle Zertifizierungen und es ist so toll,
weil der Mitgliedsstaat, der muss diese Wallet ausgeben.
Und dann muss der Mitgliedsstaat aber auch benennen, welche Firmen diese Wallet
zertifizieren müssen, damit sie sicher ist.
Und das machen sie auch nicht nach einem europa -einheitlichen Scheme,
den gibt es nämlich noch nicht, den wird es in ein paar Jahren geben.
Sondern die Mitgliedstaaten müssen sich eben selber zu Zertifizierungen ausdenken,
was es denn heißt, dieses Ding sicher zu machen.
Und da wissen wir schon, das wird sehr unterschiedlich sein.
Das BSI in Deutschland hat da eher die Ansicht, das kann nicht auf dem Smartphone sein.
Wir vertrauen auch diesen Security -Chips und das Secure Enclave nicht,
lieber noch mal eine Chipkarte dazu.
Und in Italien ist es halt eher so, YOLO, User Space in der App reicht schon.
Und das sind ja immer irgendwie die privaten Schlüssel der Identität der Bevölkerung,
mit denen man sich ausweisen kann.
Das auf ein europaeinheitliches Niveau zu heben oder zu senken, wird noch spannend.
Und ursprünglich war auch vorgesehen, dass man die App zertifizieren muss,
ob sie denn der DSGVO entspricht.
Das ist jetzt optional. Das wollen die Mitgliedstaaten nicht verpflichtend haben,
sprich, da wird es auch einige Staaten geben, die das einfach weglassen.
Diese App wird Open Source sein, das ist eher ein guter Punkt,
aber die Einschränkung dazu kommt, dass nur der Applikationsteil Open Source ist, nicht das Backend.
Und es gibt auch da die Möglichkeit, dass Staaten sagen, den Code gehen wir
nicht raus, aufgrund von Sicherheitsbedingungen.
Und das ist auch sehr breit und kann alles bedeuten.
Ja, und zuletzt der Teil, der jetzt noch nicht fertig ist, ist die ganze technische
Implementierung. Wie soll denn der Shit überhaupt funktionieren?
Und wenn das Gesetz dann final beschlossen ist, was wahrscheinlich im Februar
nächsten Jahres passieren wird, Anfang Februar, dann läuft eine Uhr und sechs
Monate hat die Kommission Zeit, genau den technischen Standard auf den Tisch zu legen,
der dann auch wirklich definieren soll, wie das europaweit zusammenspielen soll.
Wie funktioniert diese Wallet?
Und da ist auch unheimlich wenig Zeit. Es gibt seit zwei Jahren so eine Arbeitsgruppe,
die sich mit diesem technischen Standard beschäftigt.
Und die letzten Versionen davon sind meilenweit entfernt von den Safeguards,
die wir jetzt gerade beschlossen haben.
Also die fehlen alle. Dort gibt es immer noch Unique Identifier,
da gibt es keine Unlinkability und so weiter.
Also da ist viel zu tun, damit das überhaupt dem Gesetz entspricht.
Aber wie kann man, ich versteh's auch nicht.
Leute geht doch einfach zu den großen Herstellern und redet mit denen und fragt
einfach wie man das korrekt umsetzt.
Das willst du auch nicht? Weil dann sind sie bei Google und Facebook und die
erklären ihnen das bereitwillig.
Nicht Facebook.
Plattformhersteller.
Google ist der größte Plattformhersteller?
Ja, Google ist der größte.
Ah, der zweite größte möchtest du dann lieber, ne?
Nein, guck mal, es macht doch keinen Sinn irgendwas. Nein, du musst natürlich,
also wenn du dich mit Google und mit Apple zusammensetzt und sagst lass mal
eine ordentliche Sicherheitsarchitektur, die auch auf dem Betriebssystem und
irgendwie large scale mit irgendwie N Milliarden Usern wirklich funktioniert.
Und wo es wirklich eine Perspektive gibt, dass wir eine internationale Interoperabilität
hinbekommen. Das ist möglich.
Das bauen die übrigens gerade selber ein. Die haben schon die Technik für irgendwie
Führerschein ablegen etc. Ausweise.
Das kommt gerade sowieso und das sind auch genau, sage ich jetzt mal voraus,
in 10 Jahren wird das genau der Standard sein.
Wir erlauben uns jetzt bloß noch den Tanz, noch mal Milliarden an Geld für sinnlose
Apps rauszuschmeißen, die am Ende nicht sicher sein werden, nicht funktionieren
werden, nicht skalieren, alles mögliche nicht tun werden,
um dann am Ende dann doch irgendwie auf diesem Pfad einzulenken.
Also das ist einfach, das macht mich fassungslos.
Ich meine mal ehrlich, sechs Monate Zeit nach Gesetzesabschluss,
wo man einen politischen Willen gemacht hat und dann soll die Technik kommen,
die diesen politischen Wunsch umsetzt.
Von ebenfalls Fachkräften.
Ja das ist doch vollkommen illusorisch, das können die doch komplett backen.
Also insofern bin ich gerade nicht beunruhigt, weil die werden ihren politischen
Wunsch nicht technisch umgesetzt bekommen.
Ja, das denke ich mir selber. Das höre ich auch von manchen Verhandlern so.
Okay, wir haben unser Bestes gegeben. Ob das Ding irgendwie am Ende funktioniert
oder wir es verwenden werden, ist komplett offen.
Aber die EU hat da halt mit enormen Druck irgendwie gearbeitet.
Circa 50 Millionen sind bisher schon so in Projekte geflossen,
um zum Beispiel das Sozialsystem an diese Wallet anzubieten.
Ich glaube, Deutschland hat auch ungefähr 100 Millionen ausgegeben.
Da ist auch ganz viel Blockchain bei diesen ganzen Förderprogrammen dabei,
was auch beunruhigend ist.
Und ja, also zu dieser Frage hätte man es nicht die großen Plattformen machen lassen können.
Also es gibt diesen ISO -MDL, also ISO -Standard für Mobile Driving License,
der in den USA gerade rechtsverbindlich wird.
Und der versucht genau das. Der ist auch aus Datenschutzsicht relativ gut.
Hat Unlinkability zum Beispiel auch.
Und gleichzeitig aber, das was man mit Wallet meint, ist ja mehr als ein einziges
Attribut ausweisen zu können, sondern echt so eine Plattform zu machen.
Und es gibt zum Beispiel die Open Wallet Foundation, die ein Projekt der Linux
Foundation ist, die genau da jetzt versucht, so einen Mittelweg zu finden,
weil Google eben nicht alleine das machen kann.
Weil über so eine Wallet kannst du auch wahnsinnig viel Geld verdienen.
Und da könnte dann auch Samsung oder andere Android -Gerätehersteller vielleicht nicht mitspielen.
Die hätten dann lieber vielleicht ihre eigene Wallet drauf.
Also es gibt gerade viel Bewegung, da so einen einheitlichen Standard zu schaffen.
Und ich sehe da viel Licht und Schatten. Also das geht auch in die Richtung
digitale Bezahlmodelle.
Einerseits ist Datenschutz da immer ein Lippenbekenntnis. Gleichzeitig die Gefahr
in der Praxis für Menschen, Wenn du jetzt gerade in den globalen Süden schaust,
was digitale Identität dort angerichtet hat, das ist enorm.
Gerade auch bei der UNO und bei der Weltbank gibt es riesige Programme dazu,
das in die Breite zu tragen.
Da ist gerade extrem viel Dynamik in diesem Thema drin.
Ich hoffe, dass manche der Safeguards aus Europa weltweit übernommen werden.
Aber ob das, was Europa hier baut, das ist halt wie jede Netzpolitikregulierung
in Europa so. Will it work?
We don't know.
Wir haben ein Gesetz geschrieben, schauen wir mal. Die Ideen sind schön,
die Sprache liest sich toll. Mal schauen, ob es funktioniert.
Also ich glaube, das wird garantiert so nicht in sechs Monaten sinnvoll spezifizierbar sein.
Und gerade mit diesem, also Selective Disclosure,
Unlinkability, Zero Knowledge, kein Unique Identifier, das geht alles,
das ist ohne Frage sind die Technologien da,
aber ich muss auch sagen, dass ich die glaube ich allenfalls in sehr basalen
Implementierungen bisher gesehen habe, die sicherlich nicht geeignet sind.
Und diejenigen, die damit mehr Erfahrung haben, werden dem widersprechen,
weil sie dem System mehr zutrauen, aber die jetzt nicht unbedingt einen Reifegrad haben, dass man,
sagen wir mal innerhalb von sechs Monaten sagt, darauf stellen wir jetzt das
Identifikationswesen unserer Staatengemeinschaft aus.
Also das ist immer noch ein relativ großer Schritt, wie ich finde.
Ich kann dir da absolut zustimmen und das ist auch genau das, was ich höre.
Also ich habe da natürlich eine Vernetzung mit Leuten,
die den ISO -Standard mitgeschrieben haben, die die W3C -Standards zu diesem
Thema mitgeschrieben haben und was ich auch von diesen Autorinnen und Autoren dieser Standards höre,
die wirklich alles kennen, was in dem Feld basiert, teilweise an Uni -Professoren
und so und die sagen auch,
ja theoretisch gibt es da ein Paper dazu und da gibt es auch die oder die Pilotimplementierung.
Aber fertig für die breite Ausrollung ist das alles noch nicht.
Also da brauchen wir locker noch
ein paar Jahre, bis das stabil für den Produktiveinsatz verwendbar ist.
Aber man hat das halt eilig gehabt und man wollte es unbedingt schon vorgestern,
das Gesetz, beschließen.
Und das ist ja, in der Praxis wird es da wahrscheinlich ein böses Erwachen geben,
ob das am Ende so funktioniert.
Und das Lustige ist ja, wenn dieses Ding dann trotzdem angeboten wird,
weil man die dann einhalten will,
überleg dir mal, jemand verwendet das und kommt dann bei einer Downtime von
einer Woche oder einem Tag nicht mehr in seine Bank, zu seinem ÖPNV -Ticket,
in sein Instagram rein, in irgendwelche E -Government -Services nicht mehr rein.
Und den digitalen Euro gibt es dann auch noch auf dieser Wallet.
Also das ist schon ein enormer Single Point of Failure, den wir da gebaut haben.
Aber ist es denn ein Single -Point -Affair? Ich hätte jetzt gedacht,
am Ende muss jeder nur ein paar Zertifikate installieren und der Rest läuft.
Also das war nicht, da wollte ich dich nämlich gerade schon fragen,
mit dem Unobservability, das hast du ja irgendwie, also, weil sie müssen ja,
also sie müssen das ja nicht observen.
Beispiel Corona Impfpass Nachweis war ja dann am Ende so, dass das, was du dort vorzeigst,
zumindest signiert ist von einer ausgebenden Stelle und du musst jetzt nicht
die ausgebende Stelle nochmal kontaktieren,
um dich zu vergewissern, dass das, was du da hast, irgendwie richtig oder in Ordnung ist.
Das Problem ist halt auch, wir hatten bei den Impfzertifikaten oder Genesungszertifikaten
von Corona einen sehr spezifischen Anwendungsfall, auf den genau wir hindesignen konnten.
Hier haben wir eine General -Purpose -Architecture für alle möglichen Attribute plus deren Revocation.
Und das soll sozusagen dann auch in der Masse funktionieren,
at scale, bei beliebigen Terminals von der Polizei oder jetzt irgendwie Firmen,
die das verwenden wollen.
Also da ist halt einfach ein viel höherer Komplexitätsgrad drin.
Normalerweise würdest du für jeden
dieser Anwendungsfälle eine eigene Datenschutzfolgeabschätzung machen.
Das ist gerade in Österreich passiert, das fanden wir sehr gut,
da hat man wirklich jedes Mal jetzt Führerschein, jetzt Altersnachweis,
wie genau ist Datenschutz hier zu lesen, wie machen wir das?
Das kann es hier gar nicht geben, weil wenn dieses System designt wird,
wissen wir alle nicht, welche Attribute landen da drin, wer wird das verwenden
und wem gegenüber wird sich hier ausgewiesen. Das ist alles noch unklar,
weil es General Purpose ist.
Also es ist, es ist im Prinzip noch gar, also irgendwas was ich jetzt unter
Architekturfragen verstehen würde, ist sowieso noch nicht spezifiziert.
Kriegst du? Also es gibt die 1 .2, nein, öffentlich ist nur die 1 .0 von dem
Architecture Reference Framework, wo du die Technik mal siehst,
das ist aber auch immer noch relativ vage, insgeheim gibt es schon die 1 .2,
die ist aber noch nicht veröffentlicht, aber ich kenne sie.
Und da wird es jetzt ziemlich rapide neue Versionen geben, die halt irgendwie
versuchen, dem Gesetz zu entsprechen.
Wir werden auch wieder Analysen verfassen, um auch zu zeigen,
wo sie das noch nicht tun.
Aber ja, ob das dann am Ende dieser Übung gelingen wird, werden wir sehen.
Wenn IIDA es scheitert, dann weine ich dem keine Träne hinterher.
Mein Job war, Risiken zu minimieren.
Ich habe mir dieses Gesetz nie gewünscht.
So eine Schnapsidee, wirklich die Technik nach so einem politischen Wunsch zu
bauen. Man muss halt erstmal diese Technik im Feld haben.
Ich meine mit dieser Mobile Driving License, das ist ein ISO Standard,
aber es gibt jetzt für diese ganze EIDAS Geschichte keine klare Leitlinie,
Natürlich werden dort Standards in irgendeiner Form zur Anwendung kommen,
aber letzten Endes geht es ja um das Gesamtgebilde und vor allen Dingen den
gesamten Prozess und das scheint mir ja nicht der Fall zu sein,
dass man hier diesen Weg geht.
Also es gibt einzelne Standards, an denen man sich angelehnt hat.
Und natürlich ist das Ziel auch, Interoperabilität, wo auch immer möglich, hinzubekommen.
Wir haben auch zum Beispiel versucht, dass man alles, was hier an Protokollen
entwickelt wird, dann eben auch offen standardisiert ist und nicht irgendwie
im proprietärer Blödsinn.
Es gab da auch einige Firmen, die sehr stark für ihre eigene Lösung lobbyiert haben.
Klar.
Das ist so halbgarn. Also es ist jetzt nicht im Gesetz die Open -Source -Bestimmung wasserdicht.
Noch ist irgendwie klar geregelt, dass das nur offene Standards sein müssen.
Da ist immer noch Spielraum. Und das Problem ist auch diese Gruppe,
die technisch das Ganze ausgestalten wird.
Das sind fast nur Vertreter der Staaten. Ich kann noch mal irgendwie die Gruppe
verlinken auf der offiziellen Seite der Kommission.
Es ist sehr lustig, weil man sieht gar nichts darüber. Es ist weder klar,
wer da drinnen sitzt, noch, was da genau besprochen wird.
Man sieht ganz wenig, was dann öffentlich konsultiert wird und ich weiß zum
Beispiel von vielen Industrieakteuren, dass die super guten Informationsfluss
hier haben und dann auch so Industrieverbände mit Blockchain im Namen,
Privileged Access haben zu dem, was dort diskutiert wird.
Also ja, das lässt jetzt nicht Gutes offen.
Nochmal eine Nachfrage zu diesem politischen Prozess, diesen Trilog haben wir
ja schon immer mal wieder im Detail versucht zu erklären.
Die 20 Leute, die, sind es insgesamt 20 Leute oder 20 Leute vom Parlament,
wie hast du das vorhin gesagt?
Also ich glaube, insgesamt sind es wahrscheinlich 20 Leute. Teilweise waren
es auch wirklich weniger.
Wir hatten 19 Working Level Meetings, technische Triloge heißt das,
wo halt wirklich teilweise keine Abgeordneten im Saal waren,
sondern nur deren Assistentinnen, deren Parliamentary Staff,
die Policy Advisors der Parteien,
halt die paar Leute vom Rat und dann die Kommission.
Und teilweise war es auch so, dass vielleicht eine Person mit technischem Sachverstand
am Tisch war, manchmal zwei.
Der Rest der Leute hat einfach keinelei IT -Background, was dann halt auch super
ist, wenn du ein Gesetz schreibst, das IT regulieren soll.
Es gab im Juni einen ganz lauten großen Termin, wo man sich geeinigt hat auf
dieses Gesetz, obwohl erst ein Drittel davon durchbesprochen war zwischen Parlament und Rat.
Dann haben die Abgeordneten irgendwie den Saal verlassen und sind nicht wiedergekommen.
Also der Großteil dieser Meetings fand komplett ohne irgendjemanden am Tisch
statt, der oder die politisch legitimiert wäre oder gewählt worden wäre.
Das waren alles Public Servants oder Staffer.
Und lustigerweise gab es aber eben keine NGO und auch keine Konsumentenschutz
-NGO, die daran gearbeitet hat, außer uns.
Und ich hatte super guten Access. Also wir haben teilweise Mitgliedstaaten gesagt,
jetzt hast du schon wieder einen offenen Brief geschickt, wo du einen Text kritisierst,
den wir gar nicht kennen.
Weil die spanische Ratspräsidentschaft das halt wirklich sehr close to the chest
gespielt hat und halt wirklich so diese paar Leute das Ding ausverhandelt haben
und das war dann ziemlich friss oder stirb.
So hier ist das Ergebnis, stimmt die jetzt zu oder nicht?
Dann gab es noch mal ein paar Änderungsanträge von den Staaten,
aber zähneknirschend hat man dem zugestimmt.
Das ist demokratiepolitisch sehr bedenklich gelaufen und leider muss man sagen,
Triloge sind ganz oft so.
Also das ist nicht so, dass dann die Patrick Breyers dieser Welt mit Argus -Augen
da am Tisch sitzen, sondern ganz oft wird das delegiert an Leute und die machen dann halt einfach mal.
Und wenn man bei denen im Adressbuch steht, dann darf man irgendwie Input liefern
und darf Argumente liefern, was gut oder schlecht wäre.
Und je nachdem, wie die Leute gepolt sind, hören die halt eher auf Industrie
oder manchmal halt auch auf NGOs.
Aber wenn dann schon gar keine Gewählten mehr im Raum sind, sondern quasi nur,
was ist das dann, also welche Abteilungen stellen dann das Personal,
was da noch sitzt und verhandelt?
Also es ist immer so, du hast einerseits von der Kommission die zuständigen
Leute, das war halt DJ Connect, also das Digitalkommissariat von Thierry Petain,
die spanische Ratspräsidentschaft mit den zuständigen Ministerien.
Und dann vom Parlament, je nachdem, da können irgendwie mehr Leute dazukommen.
De facto ist es meistens so, dass halt von der Berichterstatterin in dem Fall,
Romana Jarković, immer Leute dabei waren.
Also eine Person, dann von den Shadow -Berichterstattern, also Jarković ist
Sozialdemokratin, von den anderen Parteien waren teilweise auch Leute da.
Zum Beispiel von den Rechtsextremen, AfD, FPÖ war niemals jemand anwesend.
Aber die ECR, also die ehemaligen Tories, die europaskeptischen Konservativen,
die waren sehr gut bei dem Thema, weil die jemanden hatten, der für den Liebeausschuss
Berichterstatter war. Die haben echt gute Arbeit gemacht mal.
Und wir hatten großes Gewicht am Ende beim Datenschutz, weil der Liebeausschuss
eine Zuständigkeit bei dem Thema hatte und sozusagen nicht nur der Industrieausschuss,
sondern der zweite Ausschuss mit dabei war.
Natürlich konnten wir immer wieder Dinge spiegeln und dann auch noch Staffer
vom Parlament selber, die für die Parteien oder für die Ausschüsse arbeiten.
Policy Advisor oder eben Staffer für die jeweiligen Ausschüsse.
Und da haben halt auch nicht immer alle Zeit für diese jeweiligen Termine.
Und du bist dann halt auch ein bisschen darauf angewiesen, wer sich die Zeit
nimmt für diese Verhandlung und wie wichtig das den Leuten ist.
Bei dem Thema war es halt auch so, dass niemand auf dem Radar hatte,
es ist super technisch, kompliziert, darauf hat keiner Lust.
Das ist jetzt nicht so etwas wie die Chat -Kontrolle, wo mehr politischer Druck dahinter ist.
Also dieser offene Brief, so sehr ich ihn liebe und der hat uns am Ende geholfen,
aber den hätten wir vor ein paar Monaten gebraucht, damit dem Gesetz auch mehr
Aufmerksamkeit geschenkt wird.
Aber ja, so ist es halt geworden.
Stell dir vor, es ist Trilog und keiner hat Zeit.
Ja, aber so ist es auf jeden Fall. Wie gesagt, es gibt noch ein bisschen Bewegung bei dem Text.
Wir haben auf jeden Fall dann im Dezember die Abstimmung im Rat.
Wir haben im November noch irgendwie die Abstimmung im Ausschuss und damit wird
dann auch endlich der Text öffentlich.
Und im Februar wird dann das Plenum des Europaparlaments abstimmen.
Und dann gibt es natürlich auch immer noch die Möglichkeit, dass sich hier etwas ändert.
Aber das ist immer sehr schwierig, weil da braucht es wirklich großen, großen Druck.
Und da haben wir einfach hier nie die Öffentlichkeit dafür gehabt.
Also wir kommen ja nachher noch gleich zur Chat -Kontrolle.
Mit der Öffentlichkeit von dort wird es ein bisschen wahrscheinlicher,
aber auch da ist es schwierig. So ausgemachte Trilogergebnisse sind nur sehr,
sehr selten umstimmbar und änderbar.
Ja, also müssen wir jetzt mal abwarten, was dabei rauskommt,
sagst du, ja? Also wir haben jetzt sozusagen gar keine anderen Möglichkeiten mehr.
Also an dem Gesetz was zu ändern, ist jetzt nur noch auf Arbeitsebene möglich.
Ich glaube, wenn dann wirklich die Abstimmung ist, kann es scheitern.
Und dass es aber nochmal aufgemacht wird, die Variante sehe ich als unwahrscheinlich an.
Wie gesagt, wir haben bei der Unbeobachtbarkeit und bei den Quarks noch die
Hoffnung, dass was passiert.
Bei den Quarks, bei der Transportverschlüsselung in unseren Webbrowsern,
um es richtig zu sagen, da ist es so, dass wir eben diesen Text haben,
der so good enough ist, um damit zu leben.
Ich bin immer noch nicht happy damit, aber ein guter Browser kann sich damit
wehren, dass seine Transportverschlüsselung unterwandert wird vom Staat.
Das ist auch zumindest das, was ich jetzt von Mozilla zum Beispiel höre,
und die sind diejenigen, die am Ende damit leben müssen und deren Compliance
sich das ausstreiten muss.
Glücklich ist niemand damit, aber wir werden auf jeden Fall diesen technischen
Standard mit Argus -Augen genau beobachten.
Und dann halt auch die ganze weitere Gesetzgebung, die auf IE das aufbaut.
Und mich würde es freuen, wenn es noch scheitert, wenn es passieren muss,
dann bitte so Datenschutz Grundsätzlich grundsätzlich freundlich und grundsätzlich
freundlich wie möglich.
Jetzt hast du schon gesagt, wir werden das noch weiter uns jetzt anschauen.
Wir haben uns in vorherigen Sendungen auch darüber unterhalten,
dass man potenziell das vielleicht gar nicht möchte, dass es so eine riesige
Überidentifizierung gibt.
Gleichzeitig, es gibt schon Vorzüge dieser Technologie, die man vielleicht auch
ganz gerne haben möchte,
aber dass natürlich so diese Überidentifizierung erstmal keine so rosige Idee
ist, mit allen Umständlichkeiten, die man so hat,
finde ich es doch eigentlich ganz schön, ähm, ähm, äußerst selten meinen Ausweis zu brauchen.
Ja und das würde ich auch ganz gerne beibehalten.
Das wird natürlich, wenn man jetzt sowas baut und sagt guck mal hier ist dein
Handy und dann kommt irgendein Smudo ins Fernsehen und sagt machst du bieb bieb,
dann hast du natürlich relativ rucki zucki die Leute in der Situation getrieben,
wo du sie eigentlich nicht haben willst.
Darüber werden wir in Zukunft noch mal reden. Wir haben jetzt ja von dir vor allem,
nachdem du das Thema vor längerer Zeit bei uns im Podcast ja auch eingeleitet
hast, jetzt mal gehört wie ist die Diskussion gelaufen und jetzt müssen wir
uns noch ein bisschen, wenigstens noch mal kurz mit der Chatkontrolle auseinandersetzen.
Also es gibt einmal die Sache, dass die mit der personalisierten Werbung,
darüber haben wir ja schon gesprochen, Targeting auf Basis von politischer Einstellung,
da hat die Eva Johannsen sich auch einer Anhörung zugestellt.
Hat sie da irgendwas dazu gesagt oder hat sie wieder nur gesagt,
meine Verordnung ist voll geil?
Sie hat ganz oft gesagt, dass ihr Gesetz urtoll ist und dass die Leute es nur
lesen müssen und dann werden sie das Licht sehen.
Angesprochen auf diese illegale, zielgerichtete Werbung, die ganz klar gegen
den DSE verstößt, hat sie dann gemeint, naja, das haben halt immer eine Starfer gemacht.
Also das war irgendwo meine Untergeberin, da weiß ich gar nichts drüber,
da kann ich jetzt auch keine Auskunft geben.
Also sie hat sich total weggeduckt, auch wenn es viele Fragen zu diesem Thema gab,
die Abgeordneten haben auch die Chance genutzt, weil Johannsen sich vor kurzem
auch sehr kritisch zu Edry geäußert hat und gemeint hat, ja die sind ja irgendwie
alle nur von Apple gekauft und böse und dieses sogenannten Datenschützer.
Was wirklich ein absoluter Irrsinn ist.
Also das ist wirklich das eine, das hat ja auch viele bei Edri enorm aufgeregt.
Ich gehörte eher zu denen, die gesagt haben, lass mal eher den Beiflag halten,
bevor du die Scheiße jetzt fest trittst.
Bevor demnächst jeder, wenn er Edry sagt, denen von der EU Kommission vorgeworfen
wird, sie wären von Apple gekauft, aber das war eine, also das war,
also es ist wirklich erstaunt, also das Bildzeitungsniveau ist wirklich stark
bei Eva Johansson, das ist wirklich ein … Sie ist das ja populistisch unterwegs.
Das ist, boah ist das dreckig ey.
Aber es ist ja auch so, für Datenschutz -NGOs ist es eigentlich ein Badge of Honor,
also eine Hochachtung, wenn du von einem Innenministerium angegriffen wirst
und sie ist ja die EU -Innenkommissarin und sie will Überwachung.
Und wenn wir als Datenschützer dagegen sind und sie dann sozusagen aktiv auch
die Konfrontation mit dem Datenschutz sucht, ich glaube, das hilft ihr nicht,
eine Mehrheit zu erzeugen.
Und EDRE ist halt einfach der älteste, größte Dachverband von ganz vielen NGOs,
unter anderem der NSCC und EPICENTERWORKS und allen anderen auch.
Also da gibt es auch nichts, was man über die Haltung von EDRE in dieser Sache sagen kann.
Denn die Haltung von EDRE wird von allen diesen Organisationen gemeinsam bestimmt.
Gerade bei so einem wichtigen Thema sind das auch alles Papiere,
wo ganz viele Leute draufschauen und wo wir vereint sagen, dieses Gesetz geht so einfach nicht.
Und wenn wir dafür von Apple Kohle kriegen?
Meine Güte ey, irgendwo vorn müssen wir auch leben.
Ein Quatsch ey, das ist wirklich ein bisschen schwach.
Ja, also das war sicherlich ein, man kann sich dieses Theater immer noch anschauen,
wenn man Schmerzen haben will, aber es ist auf jeden Fall, glaube ich,
nicht so gut für sie gelaufen.
Aber natürlich hat sie als Profi -Politikerin versucht, die Linie zu halten,
aber das hat ja nicht dazu geführt, dass der String an Leaks aufgehört hat.
Es wird ja unheimlich gut gerade recherchiert im Umfeld von Johansen,
mit wem sie sich so trifft.
Und das wollte sie ja nicht bekannt geben, mit wem sie da so redet, ne?
Das ist sie gefragt worden und da hat sie gesagt, das weiß ich jetzt nicht,
da kann ich keine Liste geben.
Aber man ist da hart geblieben und es gibt jetzt diese Liste auf Netzpolitik .org zu lesen.
Ja, und das war interessant, die Liste, da können wir natürlich mal kurz draufschauen,
die ist ja nicht besonders lang, ne?
Also irgendwie ein paar Uni -Leute, so, dann ein paar Leute von Microsoft,
ein paar Leute von Google, dann Mega, jemand von Mega, also das ist wahrscheinlich
die mit Mega Upload, oder?
Dann kommen die ganzen Thorn -Leute, dann kommt ein bisschen was von NECMEC,
Canadian Center for Child Protection, auch interessant, das ist die erste Kinderschutzorganisation,
angebliche Kinderschutzorganisation,
Thorn ist USA, NECMEC ist USA, dann kommt Canadia, Canadian Center for Child
Protection und dann kommt die Australian Federal Police,
Die spanische Guardia Civil und irgendwie GCHQ und Europol und du fragst dich
wieso du hast nicht eine einzige Kinderschutzorganisation aus Europa?
Ist da nicht, find ich da nicht, tut mir leid. Und ansonsten nur Bullen,
Geheimdienster, Microsoft und Google.
Und von Microsoft vier Leute, von Google vier Leute.
Und dann wagt die es zu sagen, ja Edry sind aber von Apple gekauft die Schweine,
mit denen rede ich nicht, ich rede lieber hier mit dem GCHQ,
ein Geheimdienst außerhalb der Europäischen Union.
Ein Feind, ein Feind ist Geheimdienst.
Von irgendeiner Insel vor unseren gesicherten Grenzen.
Und das ist völliger Irrsinn, oder?
Und da ist nicht eine Kinderschutzorganisation drauf.
Also Thorn behauptet, dass sie eine Kinderschutzorganisation ist,
aber die stellen halt nur so diese Filtersoftware her.
Thorn, von denen sie auch vier Leute hatte, sind die Hersteller der Software.
Also das sind die Profiteure, das sind die, für die sie das macht.
Also es ist eine Katastrophe.
Ist es. Und ich meine, da gibt es mehr Leute von Google und von Microsoft jeweils als Datenschützer.
Und das Ganze ist so bezeichnend, weil wir wissen aus den ganzen Leaks,
dass es ja massive Kritik gab, auch innerhalb der Kommission.
Und dieses Gesetz von einigen Leuten verhindert werden wollte.
Also wir haben ja auch die Legal Opinion von der Kommission selber,
die sagt, das ist eigentlich alles verfassungswidrig.
Also sie hat da sicherlich ganz viele Gründe gehabt, wieso sie,
Sie hätte es wissen können, dass das problematisch ist und so gut wie keine
Organisation aus Europa, hier, bis auf die spanische Polizei und Europol.
Und das zeigt schon irgendwie genau, welch geistes Kind dieses Gesetzes ist.
Und übrigens dann nochmal, sie hat dann irgendwie, als sie bei dem Ausschuss
so gedrängt wurde, okay, aber hat sie sich jetzt eigentlich einmal mit Edre
getroffen? Ja, ja, es gab ja diese eine Veranstaltung, wo sie Idre getroffen hätte.
Es war halt eine Panel -Veranstaltung, wo die Policy -Adviserin von Idre,
Eda Jakubowski, geniale Frau, halt irgendwie mit Johansen gestritten hat auf der Bühne.
Und danach aber irgendwie kein Gespräch wollte, nicht mal die Hand gegeben hat.
Und das hat sie dann irgendwie im Ausschuss als, aber ich hab die ja getroffen,
gewertet. Das war natürlich auch eine breite Dehnung von dem Begriff eines Meetings,
wo man sich in der Substanz über wichtige Gesetze austauscht.
Unglaublich. Unglaublich.
Das ist schon echt eine Nummer, die Ilva.
Es ist aber trotzdem auch ein bisschen was Positives zu erwähnen bei diesem Thema.
Nämlich, bei der Chat -Kontrolle gab es jetzt eine Einigung in dem zuständigen
Bürgerrechtsausschuss, dem Liebeausschuss, auf eine Version von diesem Gesetz,
und das glaubt man wirklich kaum, die mit der ursprünglichen Chat -Kontrolle
nur noch gar nichts mehr oder fast
nichts mehr zu tun hat, wo jetzt viele Expertinnen und Experten sagen,
okay, das können wir durchwinken.
Also Zähne knirschen, darauf können wir uns einlassen.
Dieser Text wurde einstimmig von allen sieben Parteien im Europaparlament ausverhandelt.
Er ist noch nicht abgestimmt, das wird er jetzt dann am 14. November, also ziemlich bald.
Was diesen Text auszeichnet, ist, dass er keinen Angriff mehr auf Verschlüsselung plant.
Verschlüsselung ist hier explizit ausgenommen.
Signal muss nichts ändern durch die Diversion des Gesetzes.
Es ist auch nicht mehr möglich, anlasslose Massenüberwachung damit zu machen.
Also man müsste zielgerichtet, verdachtsabhängig sich Daten ausleiten lassen.
Es sind auch ein paar andere Dinge dazugekommen, wie zum Beispiel,
dass wenn die Polizei illegale Inhalte wie Dokumentation von Kindesmissbrauch
findet, müssen sie künftig das auch löschen lassen bei den Betreibern.
Das ist ja nicht der Fall im Moment, wodurch ganz viel von diesen grauenvollen
Inhalten weiter im Internet zirkuliert.
Die Netzsperren, die ja auch in diesem Gesetz drinnen sind, wurden eingeschränkt
als Ultima Ratio Mittel, das nur noch ganz selten zum Einsatz kommt,
wenn eine Plattform Kinderpornografie eben nicht löscht.
Und die Alterskontrolle, die ja auch Teil der Chat -Kontrolle ist,
die ist zwar weiter im Text enthalten, aber mit einigen Safeguards,
zum Beispiel, dass die Daten sofort gelöscht werden müssen, ein Verbot von Biometrie etc.
Also auch Patrick Breyer hat sich jetzt mal positiv für diesen Text ausgesprochen.
Also man kann wirklich sagen, dieser Text im Liebeausschuss ist das Beste,
was man rausholen konnte.
Er ist nicht perfekt, aber es ist eine Version von dem Gesetz,
die wirklich fast alle Giftsäne zieht.
Und ich will kurz über den Prozess reden, was jetzt passieren wird.
Also am 14 .11. wird das im Bürgerrechtsausschuss beschlossen werden.
Nachdem alle Parteien sich darauf geeinigt haben, gehe ich auch stark davon
aus, dass das da mit großer Mehrheit angenommen wird und zwar in einer speziellen Form,
nämlich dass man sagt, wir wollen direkt mit diesem Text vom Ausschuss gleich
in die Verhandlungen mit dem Rat im Trilog eintreten.
Das muss aber trotzdem im Plenum des Europaparlaments abgenickt werden.
Das Prozedere ist so, dass am 20.
November das Ganze angekündigt wird, wenn eine Woche lang Plenum in Straßburg
ist, wenn dann nicht 71 MEPs innerhalb von einem Tag sagen, nee,
das lassen wir nicht durch, wir wollen darüber abstimmen.
Dann gibt es eine Abstimmung, wahrscheinlich so am 23. November.
Und die wird dann mit einfacher Mehrheit entschieden, ob man jetzt dieses Verhandlungsmandat
ablehnt oder es annimmt.
Wir rechnen damit, dass wahrscheinlich Elva Johansson hier schon 71 Abgeordnete
zusammenbekommen wird, um so eine Abstimmung zu erzwingen.
Die Frage ist dann halt, schafft sie es, das Verhandlungsmandat umzudrehen?
Also hat sie eine Mehrheit gegen diesen Text, der von allen Parteien aus verhandelt wurde.
Auch wenn sie das hat, gibt es erst im Dezember eine Abstimmung über das substanzielle
Gesetz selber, wo dann eben mit Änderungsanträgen diese Version von Liebe nochmal
geändert werden könnte.
Das heißt, wir sind in der sehr seltenen, ungewöhnlichen Situation,
dass jetzt mal die Gegenseite mobilisieren muss und wir eigentlich gewinnen,
wenn wir die Füße stiller halten.
Und im Rat schaut es auch ganz spannend aus, bei den Mitgliedstaaten gibt es am 4.
Dezember den nächsten Anlauf, sich zu einigen und da schaut es nämlich im Moment
so aus, dass es keine Mehrheit für irgendeine Version der Jet -Kontrolle gibt.
Also es gibt da im Moment eine Blocking Majority, also wirklich Deutschland,
Frankreich, Polen, Sowenien, andere, die jetzt einfach sagen, nein, wollen wir nicht.
Und die ist natürlich fragil, bei Mitgliedstaaten ist es auch immer so,
das Innenministerium sagt ja, andere Ministerien sagen vielleicht nein,
ist ja in Deutschland auch so.
Und das heißt aber auch, der gesamte Zeitplan, das Gesetz vor der EU -Wahl im
Juni abzuschließen, der wackelt schon ein bisschen.
Und das gibt leichten Grund zur Hoffnung.
Kann sich alles nochmal schnell drehen. Es muss nur irgendwie Frankreich umfallen
und das machen sie gerne.
Und dann gäbe es wieder die Möglichkeit dafür. Aber im Moment sieht das eigentlich relativ gut aus.
Okay, dann schauen wir mal, wie es nächste Woche aussieht.
Ich habe noch ein Announcement dazu. Manche haben es vielleicht auf Mastodon
oder Twitter gesehen. Ich verwende X nicht als Namen, ich hasse ihn.
Aber wir haben was gebaut, was für die Chat -Kontrolle gedacht war,
aber was auch vielleicht später mal ganz hilfreich ist.
Und zwar haben wir Kampagnen -Software geschrieben,
genannt Dear MEP, und das ist ein Anruftool,
um Europaabgeordnete zu erreichen und dort selber zum Lobbyisten zu werden,
vorstellig zu werden, mit der eigenen
Stimme anzurufen und Abstimmungen im Europaparlament zu beeinflussen.
Wir haben das ja damals 2019 bei der Copyright Directive schon zum Einsatz gebracht.
Da war das damals grauenvoller Spaghetti -Kot und jetzt haben wir es sauber geschrieben.
Es gab ja auch bei LNP immer wieder mal Aufrufe, dass wir Developer suchen.
Wir haben auch ein wirklich tolles Team, mit dem das Ding jetzt soweit fertig
ist, dass wir es released haben. gear .mep .eu ist die Webseite.
Wir verwenden das jetzt erst mal für die Chat -Kontrolle. sollte der Trilog
scheitern, und wir haben schlechten Text, der gefährlich ist für Ende -zu -Ende
-Verschlüsselung, werden wir das Tool auch brauchen.
Und wenn die Chat -Kontrolle abgeschlossen ist, wird das aber alles als freie
Software unter AGPL -License veröffentlicht
und soll auch wirklich für Klimabewegungen, für Migrationsthemen,
für andere NGOs ein datenschutzfreundlicher, effektiver Weg sein,
Europaabgeordnete zu kontaktieren und das Ganze ist komplett nicht kommerziell.
Wir haben auch keine Kohle dafür bekommen, haben da eher Geld ausgegeben,
25 Grad das in die Welt zu bringen und die Hoffnung ist damit halt wirklich
einen modernen Weg Abgeordneten auf den Senkel zu gehen und auch wenn sie es nicht wollen,
halt von ihren Wählerinnen und Wählern zu hören zu Themen, die denen wichtig sind.
Und das ganze Komplizierte rund um die EU ist da wegabstrahiert.
Man muss sich nicht auseinandersetzen, welcher Ausschuss, welche Uhrzeit ist
das, Brüssel oder Straßburg, wo ich anrufen muss.
Man muss wirklich nur dieses Tool aufrufen, wird geolocated für das eigene Land.
Und die Abgeordneten, die wir vorschlagen, sind auch die, die noch nicht eine klare Position haben.
Das Tool lernt auch mit, mit Feedback von Usern und soll halt wirklich so einfach
wie möglich Europa -Politik öffnen für die breitere Öffentlichkeit.
Cool, sehr schön. Das finde ich gut.
Richtig konkrete Werkzeuge bauen, mit denen man wirklich was erreichen kann. Das ist immer das Beste.
Das war es zur Chat -Kontrolle, glaube ich, oder? Es ist außergewöhnlich positive Nachrichten.
Hättest du mal vorher sagen sollen, dann hätte ich hier noch einen passenden Jingle eingespielt.
So gut ist es aber nicht, das verschreißt nicht Tim.
Naja mal gucken, wenn das dann zur Abstimmung kommt, dann kann ich ja nochmal
ein bisschen Trigger happy sein.
Ja es muss auf jeden Fall, dann kann ich sie auch nochmal über die Details reden,
ich habe jetzt High Level versucht zusammenzufassen, sie kennen sich da viel besser aus.
Wo ich aber auch was dazu sagen wollte, ist nochmal so diese UN Cybercrime Convention.
Oh, das haben wir im Kommentar unterberichtet. Was machen Sie mir jetzt wieder
illegal? Was darf ich jetzt nicht mehr?
Wenn es nach China geht, wird irgendwie Fake News illegal.
Scheiße.
Dieser Podcast hat ein Problem.
Das war's, zwölf Jahre. Fertig.
Alternative Netzpolitik machen wir.
Truth .social. Truth .netzpolitik. Auf jeden Fall.
Ich muss das Thema einleiten mit einer Danksagung an Andreas und seine Frau.
Das sind besonders treue Hörer dieses, also Andreas ist treuer Hörer dieses Podcast.
Und wir haben ja in einer vorherigen Folge mal gefragt, ob es nicht jemanden
gibt, der vielleicht so Unterkunft stellen könnte.
Und sind dankenswerterweise, das ist meine Kollegin Tanja, dort eine Woche lang
in Brooklyn untergekommen. Und die waren super nett und da wollten wir uns einfach
bedanken, sollte Andreas hier zuhören.
Und ich fand es auch ganz lustig, wie seine amerikanische Frau euch beide nennt.
Es war nämlich so, the funny germans.
Ja.
Wir sind the funny germans.
The funny germans sind wir.
Geil.
The funny germans.
Das finde ich gut.
Auf jeden Fall großen Dank, André.
You listen to the funny Germans, we are here for you in your podcast feed.
Deutsch, aber lustig.
Die Hörerschaft von LMP ist global. Das hat uns an der Stelle wirklich geholfen.
Und nochmal Andreas, vielen, vielen Dank.
Aber zu dem Text selber, weil da hört es auf, lustig zu werden,
also wir hatten jetzt gerade eben vor ein paar Monaten die Sitzung im August
in New York bei der UNO, wirklich bombastisches Gebäude, zwei Wochen durchverhandelt.
Davor gab es schon einen sogenannten Zero Draft, das war der Vorschlag,
worauf man sich denn nicht einigen könnte.
Und der wurde komplett zerfetzt. Also der war in manchen Dingen so, wie wir ihn wollten,
und hat zum Beispiel den breiten Anwendungsbereich auf alle möglichen Straftatbestände
reduziert auf das, was wirklich im Kern Cybercrime ist und nicht jedes Verbrechen,
das im oder um einen Computer begangen wurde.
Es sind jetzt wieder die ganzen Inhaltsstraftatbestände drinnen,
wo halt wirklich die Meinungsfreiheit gefährdet ist.
Die Überwachungsbestimmungen, die wir herausverhandelt hatten,
sind jetzt wieder drinnen.
Also Special Investigation Techniques, die nicht näher definiert sind.
Da kann sich dann jeder Mitglied statt selber überlegen, was er gemeint damit.
Real -Time Interception von Inhaltsdaten und Metadaten ist wieder drinnen.
Und da haben wir natürlich dagegen gehalten. UN -Menschenrechtsbüro war auch
sehr laut diesbezüglich.
Die sind auch wirklich gute Verbündete im Raum bei diesen Themen,
aber wir haben es da halt wirklich mit der gesamten Weltpolitik zu tun.
Es ist die EU und da zählt auch natürlich alle Mitgliedstaaten,
Deutschland, Österreich, alle sind hier einigermaßen auf der guten Seite.
Die USA drehen sich langsam, sagen jetzt auch immer öfter, sie wollen mehr Safeguards,
sie sagen aber auch, dass sie eigentlich nicht nur die Überwachung bei den genannten
Straftaten beständen wollen, sondern eigentlich bei allem, was so genanntes Serious Crime ist.
Und auf der Gegenseite hast du halt Russland, China, Indien,
Nordkorea, Syrien, Venezuela, auch Ägypten.
Und es sind halt wirklich viele Hardliner, die sich halt immer mehr durchsetzen.
Und die wollen halt mehr Kompetenzen und noch mehr Straftatbestände und Human
Rights sind dort ein Trigger -Wort.
Also ich erinnere mich noch, Ägypten sagt wirklich so, Also wir haben 25 Mentionen
des Wortes Menschenrechte in diesem Vertrag.
Das ist kein Menschenrechtsvertrag, sondern ein Verfassungsvertrag.
Und du hast dann so diese Partikulare Interessen.
Pakistan sagt, wir müssen Blasphemie unter Strafe stellen, weil was ist,
wenn dir irgendjemand nochmal so über Mohammed schlecht redet?
Und China kommt mit ganz vielen Fight Against Terror Argumenten.
Also es ist wirklich problematisch, vor allem wenn man weiß,
das ist halt ein globales Treaty.
Und wenn man da keine Safeguards drinnen hat, wie Kanadese zum Beispiel fordert,
es ist halt schwul zu sein.
LGBTQI ist halt einfach in vielen Ländern gleichgesetzt mit Sodomie oder mit
ganz anderen Straftatbeständen.
Und dadurch werden Menschen, die eigentlich geschützt gehören,
kommen ins Fadenkreuz von internationalen Ermittlungsanordnungen.
Und so einer der Safeguards, den wir uns da wünschen, der nicht im Text drinnen ist.
Wenn jetzt irgendwie Pakistan kommt, so diesen LGBTQI -Aktivisten,
der sich da für Rechte von Schwulen einsetzt, da wollen wir jetzt aber mal irgendwie
die Rufdatenauskunft haben und den Standort haben.
Ein Recht für den Staat, sich dann zu weigern aus Menschenrechtsgründen,
ist dann noch nicht drin.
Das sind so Sachen, die würden wir gerne drinnen haben.
Aber darüber wird immer noch gestritten. Also das Ausgangsstadium ist sehr schlecht.
Und jetzt haben wir die nächste Verhandlungsrunde, 29. Jänner bis 9.
Februar wieder in New York. Es ist unklar, ob das die letzte Runde ist,
weil einfach die Positionen sehr weit auseinander liegen.
Es wird noch weitere Meetings und Intercessions geben, aber ob es eine große
Runde gibt, ist sehr unklar, weil die Madame Chair, die dem Ganzen vorsteht,
eine algerische Diplomatin, die hat schon klar gesagt, dass sie mit Februar
in Ruhe stand, in Pension.
Und die macht dann einen Mic -Drop und sagt so, macht euch euren Shit selber.
Und wir haben aber im Juni die harte Deadline, wo das eigentlich in der UN General
Assembly beschlossen werden sollte. Man müsste das Mandat verändern,
was auch wieder Geld kostet, was scheinbar nicht vorhanden ist im Moment.
Und ja, also das Ganze könnte auch scheitern, was für uns, das haben wir auch
klar gesagt in New York, a better no treaty than a bad treaty.
Also, dass da jetzt mit der Flagge der UN ein so schlechter Standard gesetzt wird,
der dann weltweit gilt und vor allem die Zusammenarbeit zwischen Law Enforcement
Agencies weltweit regeln soll, Das wäre wirklich ein großer Flurschaden für unsere Grundrechte.
Deswegen sind wir da weiter dran und es bleibt spannend.
Aber ist ja nun auch nicht so, dass jetzt UN -Resolutionen bzw.
In dem Fall diese UN -Treaties jetzt besonders großen Anklang finden in den
nationalen Gesetzgebungen.
Ist ja jetzt nicht wie so eine europäische Verordnung, die dann automatisch
gilt, sondern das ist ja sozusagen genau genommen für die Staaten ja auch mehr
oder weniger nur so ein Orientierungspapier.
Es kommt darauf an. Also du brauchst eine Zweidrittelmehrheit aller 190 Staaten,
damit dieses UN -Treaty überhaupt als UN -Treaty angenommen wird.
Und ab dann ist es sozusagen ein weltweiter Vertrag und setzt auch einen globalen Standard.
An dem werden sich ganz viele andere Verhandlungen dann auch orientieren.
Für die einzelnen Mitgliedstaaten hat der Vertrag aber nur eine rechtliche Bindung,
wenn sie ihn ratifizieren.
Und die Ratifizierung bedeutet auch, dass man ihn in nationales Recht umsetzt.
Und dann gibt es natürlich noch mal dieses Element der Kooperation zwischen Staaten,
dass du von dem jetzigen System der bilateralen Abkommen, der Mutual Legal Assist Treaties, wegkommst,
und auf Basis von diesem einheitlichen Dokument strafverfolgungsbehörden auch
bilateral miteinander arbeiten können.
Vielleicht auch ohne, dass es da jetzt einen konkreten Vertrag zwischen Venezuela
und Deutschland gibt zum Beispiel.
Das kommt hier noch dazu. Aber ja, wenn zum Beispiel die USA sich am Ende dagegenstellen,
dann würde es dem Vertrag sicherlich schaden, dann wird er weniger ernst genommen,
weil die Amis haben halt einen Großteil der Firmen, um deren Daten es geht.
Und wenn man dann nicht auf Google zugreifen könnte, nimmt das natürlich dem
Ganzen so ein gewisses Gewicht. Ja.
All right. Nächstes Thema. Irgendwas mit Staatstrojanern vielleicht noch?
Ja, tut mir leid, die guten Nachrichten werden neutralisiert,
aber ich wollte nur ganz kurz reden darüber, dass in Österreich wieder Bemühungen
passieren, den Staatstrojaner zu legalisieren.
Also es wird im Moment keine Chance ausgelassen, da vom Innenministerium,
von den Nachrichtendiensten,
von dem Bundeskriminalamt zu fordern, dass man doch bitte staatliches Hacking legalisieren soll.
Und wir kennen das Spiel, egal ob ein Terroranschlag gelingt oder scheitert,
es ist immer die Antwort auf eine Überwachung.
So auch geschehen, als rund um die Regenbogenparade, den Christopher Street
Day, ein Anschlag verhindert wurde.
In der jetzigen aufgeheizten Situation im Nahostkonflikt, wo es auch schon erste
Inzidenzen und Fälle rund um jüdische Einrichtungen in Wien gab,
sind diese Forderungen natürlich auch wiedergekommen.
Also man lässt da jetzt gerade nichts aus. Und es gibt aber in Österreich ein
Urteil vom Höchstgericht aus 2019, das ganz klar sagt, Staatstrojaner ist illegal.
Und nur so ein Tittbit, weil das ist wieder die lustige Sache,
am Nationalfeiertag gab es auch im Verfassungsgerichtshof einen Tag der offenen
Tür und die Sprecherin vom Höchstgericht hat angesichts dieser ständigen Forderungen
auch noch mal daran erinnert,
so wir haben das eigentlich schon entschieden, wir könnten uns diese Debatte auch sparen.
Und ich finde das ist eine neue Taktik, dass Höchstgerichte irgendwie so PR
-Strategien und Tage der offenen Tür auf ihre Urteile.
Schauen sie mal, was wir da schon geschrieben haben.
Das ist lustig. Ja, das könnte das Bundesverfassungsgericht hier in Deutschland
auch ab und zu mal machen, so ein Tag der offenen Tür.
Muss ich sagen, so hier, das könnte er ja auch vergessen.
Das wäre hilfreich. Ja, das war's.
Wir haben dann noch eine kurze Meldung, der wir uns mal irgendwie in der nächsten
Sendung noch tiefer nähern müssen.
Das Oberlandesgericht in Köln hat letzte Woche entschieden, dass Cloudflare
als Betreiber eines Content Delivery Networks als Täter haftet.
Cloudflare ist relativ groß.
Cloudflare, da laufen gefühlt alle Webseiten der Welt auf.
Das Internet. Das Internet ist Täter. Wir haben es erwischt.
Tatort Internet. Jetzt haben wir ihn endlich gefunden.
Den Internet.
Also Cloudflare, da ging es
um ein Album, das über die Domain ddl -musik mit c .to vertrieben wurde.
Die Domain gibt's aber glaube ich nicht mehr, die haben wegen rechtlicher Probleme
den Betrieb eingestellt, haben halt einfach Musik zum Download angeboten.
Sondern jetzt ist die Musikindustrie quasi gegen Cloudflare vorgegangen und hat gesagt,
ihr müsst hier bitte auch Dinge löschen und das ist schon ein bisschen irre.
Sie haben ja mit Qua -Nein den DNS -Resolver angegriffen, jetzt ein CDN.
Das finde ich irgendwie wirklich schwierig nachvollziehbar, wie man zu einem
solchen Urteil kommen kann und wie man zu einer solchen Rechtsauffassung kommen kann.
Ich meine das sind, klar am Ende geht's denen darum, wir wollen bei euch Löschanforderungen
durchsetzen und dann macht's natürlich auch Sinn, also zu sagen,
wenn eh die Hälfte des Internets bei Cloudflare ist,
dann schicken wir halt unsere Löschanordnungen oder unsere Löschwünsche an Cloudflare.
Klar, das ist eine Adresse, ist einfacher.
Und da spielt natürlich denjenigen, die Dinge aus dem Internet löschen wollen,
spielt ein solches Urteil natürlich sehr in die Hände.
Ich kann mir aber wirklich irgendwie nicht vorstellen, dass die in Köln wussten,
was die da entscheiden. Weil das wirklich eine irre Entscheidung ist.
Also der Last kann Cloudflare ja gar nicht nachkommen an lösch das von deiner
Seite. Die sind ja nun wirklich nicht dafür verantwortlich.
Ja, vor allem das ist ja ein purer Dienstleister für die anderen Webseiten.
Also als nächstes gehen sie hinter Western Digital her und sagen,
ich hab die Festplatte hergestellt.
Ganz klar, steht doch euer Name drauf. Hier, Western Digital.
Aber das ist, also das ist,
oh man Leute, vor allem, man hatte eigentlich ja gedacht, dass sie gerade diesen
Sachverhalt mit wer ist dafür verantwortlich, dass etwas im Internet ist,
dass sich der so langsam rumgesprochen hatte.
Jungs, ich bin zuversichtlich, das wird im 21. Jahrhundert, wird das alles besser.
Ja?
Mh. Oh, ist ja schon.
Schade, ja, ist jetzt bald um.
Ist bald vorbei und es hat immer noch keiner gecheckt.
Ja, das ist irre. Bald schafft das Internet schon wieder ab,
weil wir sagen, komm, das hat einfach zu viel Ärger gemacht.
Aber da hätte man gedacht, das hätte man inzwischen noch gedacht, kann man lösen.
Genau, wenn das Internet kaputt ist, dann gehen wir ins Unternet.
Internetbrowser.
Also es ist nämlich wirklich so, dass nicht nur beim Digital Services Act ist
ganz klar, dass reine Vermittler, reine Casher da nicht in der Haftung sind
und erst recht nicht selbst Täter sind.
Und das ist nicht seit dem DSE so, sondern schon seit der 2000er E -Commerce
-Richtlinie. Also das Gesetz ist 23 Jahre alt, wo schon drinsteht,
dass du, wenn du Dinge durchleitest, bist du nicht selber verantwortlich.
Wie auch irgendwie der Telefonbetreiber nicht für die Bombendrohung verantwortlich ist.
Die selbe Logik gilt hier natürlich auch, weil Cloudflare, das ist ja vor allem
wahrscheinlich auch die Gratisversion des Dienstes.
Also ich hab das Urteil jetzt nicht gelesen, aber es hat sich geändert.
Deswegen, ich bin da gerade vorsichtig, also es gibt hier, also das Urteil gibt's doch nicht.
Alles was es gibt ist irgendwie unter musikindustrie .de oder was,
dass sie stolz sind, dass sie mal wieder irgendwo das Recht verbogen haben.
Aber deswegen würde ich gerne das Urteil sehen, weil hier spezifisch steht CDN,
also Cloudflare als CDN und Cloudflare bietet auch ein CDN an.
Und dann wäre das zumindest etwas potenziell was anderes,
zu sagen, du musst auf deinem CDN einer Löschanforderung nachkommen,
kann ich zumindest irgendwie juristisch eher nachvollziehen.
Oder sagen wir mal, technisch eher nachvollziehen als zu sagen,
du bist eigentlich ein Proxy für High Availability und du cachest nur und muss
jetzt da einer Löschanforderung nachkommen.
Ich vermute, dass sie sich an den Cloudflare CDN Teil hier gewendet haben.
Jaja, es gibt halt spezifische Bestimmungen für Hoster und Cacher,
Caching -Dienstleistungen, und die sind eigentlich auch dann ja maximal sozusagen
zur Löschung aufgerufen und haften auch, wenn sie den Löschanforderungen nicht nachkommen.
Aber sie sind selber nicht Täter und die Musikindustrie meint hier,
sie wären zum Täter ernannt worden.
Also kann auch sein, dass ja die Musikindustrie einfach nur das Urteil sehr
kreativ in ihrem Sinne umdeutet und das Gericht was ganz anderes gesagt hat.
Also ja, muss man beobachten und vielleicht auch mal Cloudflare fragen,
was da wirklich passiert ist. Die sollten es ja wissen, wenn sie da verurteilt wurden.
So, willst du noch irgendwas, hast du noch irgendwelche Jobs zu verteilen?
Ja, wir suchen gerade wieder. Und zwar Trainerinnen suchen wir für die Epicenter Academy.
Das ist so ein neuer Arm, den wir gerade aufbauen, weil über Jahre immer wieder
Anfragen kommen, geht doch mehr an Schulen, wir brauchen mehr Vorträge und digitale
Grundbildung ist da wirklich was Wichtiges.
Und deswegen haben wir dieses Jahr die Epicenter Academy gegründet.
Das ist wirklich so eine eigene Rechtspersönlichkeit, die diese Angebote,
diese Bildungsangebote anbieten soll. ist schon in fast allen Berufsschulen
in Niederösterreich gewesen, also da, wo Lehrlinge ausgebildet wurden.
Und wir haben da auch ein E -Learning -Programm für die Oberstufe und Sekundarstufe
2 und ist sicherlich auch für Erwachsene im Einstiegsniveau geeignet,
wo es halt wirklich so um digitale Selbstverteidigung geht und,
Grundkompetenzen beim Datenschutz, auch wie schütze ich mich vor Phishing -Attacken und so weiter.
Das E -Learning ist komplett frei, CC BY und auch mit H5P Elementen gut in E
-Learning Plattformen einzubauen.
Hintergrund ist, wir haben jetzt ein Schulfach digitaler Grundbildung in Österreich.
Wir haben auch Laptops in allen Klassen, wir haben auch Internet an allen Schulen,
aber die Inhalte fehlen.
Und eine Hauptzielgruppe von uns sind gerade Lehrkräfte, die halt was unterrichten
sollen, wovon sie selber nicht unbedingt viel Ahnung haben.
Und da expandieren wir gerade massiv, weil wir sehen, da ist echt ein schöner
Bedarf da und auch Berufsgeheimnistikerinnen sind so eine Zielgruppe,
um die wir uns kümmern wollen.
Und dafür brauchen wir Trainerinnen und Trainer.
Und da gibt es jetzt gerade einen Call, den wir verlinken. Man muss dafür in
Österreich sein, also Leute können von überall her kommen, aber Dienstort ist
jetzt mal Österreich, weil da ist der Bedarf, um den wir uns kümmern wollen.
Aber das E -Learning ist natürlich für alle frei und wer niederschwellig einfach
verständliche Inhalte zu Digitalthemen sucht oder auch selber vielleicht unterrichtet,
der kann das gerne verwenden.
Wie gesagt, das ist Open Educational Resource und CC BY, also kann auch von
allen für beliebige Zwecke verwendet werden und wird von uns auch gepflegt und ständig ausgebaut.
Super Aktion.
Und was sucht ihr da jetzt für einen Job? Also ich dachte, ihr habt da einen Job anzubieten.
Ja, ja, man kann auch Trainerin werden.
Ah, Trainer.
Ja, also weil die Academy sucht eben, da ist jetzt noch die Einreichfrist bis zum 27. November.
Und da kann man sich sozusagen melden. Wir haben hier unterschiedliche Modelle
und das ist alles auf der Webseite verlinkt.
Und man kriegt natürlich die Trainerinnenausbildung. Also es ist nicht notwendig,
dass man jetzt irgendwie aus der Technik oder aus dem Lehrberuf kommt.
Wobei es natürlich gut ist, wenn es Leute sind, die mit diesen Themen was anfangen können.
Natürlich geht es auch um Didaktik. Wir wollen das zielgruppengereicht rüberbringen.
Also das Ziel ist wirklich, das Niveau von allen zu heben, unabhängig davon,
wie groß das Vorwissen ist.
Und wenn man Spaß am Gerät hat und auch vielleicht Spaß mit anderen Menschen
in so einer Situation umzugehen und zu unterrichten, dann wäre das wirklich ein spannender Job.
Und wir würden uns freuen, wenn wir da viele motivierte Leute finden können.
Wie gesagt, man muss halt leider nur in Österreich sein dafür.
Es gab schon irgendwie auf Mastern und Leute aus Deutschland,
die gemeint haben, aber ich will auch im Moment leider nicht.
Wir sind eine österreichische und europäische NGO.
Ich glaube, in Deutschland gibt es genügend andere Angebote und ja,
ist auf jeden Fall eine Möglichkeit, die es jetzt noch bis zum Ende November
gibt, sich da zu bewerben.
Wie kommst du jetzt auf den Eindruck, dass es in Deutschland genügend andere Angebote gibt?
Ihr seid so groß und es gibt doch Chaos macht Schule und so andere Dinge.
Und das genügt? Also hast du den Eindruck, dass mit dem Genügen habe ich jetzt irgendwie...
Es gibt andere Angebote, ja.
Weiß ich auch nicht genau wovon du redest.
Mit dem Genug...
Genug ist ja auf jeden Fall eine super Maßnahme, was ihr da macht.
Auch die ganze Idee da mit der Academy, sozusagen nicht nur jetzt im reinen
politischen Lobby -Policy -Bereich unterwegs zu sein, sondern im Prinzip das
Ganze auch in die Schulen zu tragen.
Ja, wir haben über die 14 Jahre, die es im Verein gibt, ganz viele Ideen gehabt
und an uns herangetragen bekommen, was nicht noch alles spannend wäre,
weil das Internet und ihr kennt euch da ja aus, wollt ihr nicht das oder das oder das machen.
Immer nein gesagt, aber bei dem Bildungsthema ist es einfach so,
du kommst nicht ans Ziel, wenn gewisse Grundkenntnisse und Fertigkeiten nicht
von den Leuten selbst beherrscht werden Und deswegen macht es total Sinn,
sich nochmal spezifisch darum zu kümmern, aber eben nicht im Verein,
sondern bei einer GmbH, die aber dem Verein gehört, insofern gemeinnützig agiert,
damit das einfach auch seine Zeit hat, weil neben der politischen Arbeit geht
das immer unter, das braucht eine eigene Organisation,
die sich nur darum kümmert.
Und das soll das sein, diese Epicenter Academy.
Wir haben sie im Sommer gegründet und Epicenter .academy ist es mal wirklich
der Versuch, dem Thema gerecht zu werden.
Und mal schauen, wie gut das Ganze gelingt. Wir freuen uns auf jeden Fall,
wenn auch schon das E -Learning irgendwie Leuten helfen kann,
weil das ist jetzt schon voll verfügbar.
Wir haben eine Anschubfinanzierung von der Arbeiterkammer in Österreich bekommen,
die Konsumentenschutzorganisation. Deswegen konnten wir das überhaupt irgendwie in die Welt bringen.
Und der Versuch ist jetzt halt wirklich mal Angebote zu schaffen,
dass wirklich jeder, der dieses Wissen abrufen will, das auch bekommt.
Und für die Schulen natürlich mit Förderung, dass es gratis ist.
Wenn irgendwelche KMUs anfragen, dann zahlen die natürlich dafür.
Das E -Learning wird immer gratis sein.
Alright, dann sind wir jetzt bei den Terminen angekommen.
Ja vom 37c3 läuft ja schon der CFP, auch läuft der CFP für den Winterkongress
der digitalen Gesellschaft Schweiz. Der findet allerdings erst am 1. und 2.
März statt im Casinotheater in Winterthur.
Aber am 3. Dezember wird der CFP geöffnet. Wir sollten jetzt schon drauf hinweisen.
Könnt ihr euch jetzt schon Gedanken drüber machen?
3. Dezember ist, ich glaub da gibt's die Zusage vom 37c3, da könnt ihr also
potenziell euren abgelehnten... nein, bitte nicht.
Es reicht also unter Umständen gerade noch einen beim 37c3 abgelehnten Vortrag bei uns einzureichen.
Achso, nein, Entschuldigung, bis zum 3. Dezember, okay, sorry,
sorry, sorry, sorry, alles falsch, also, bis am 3.
Dezember, in Deutschland sagt man bis zum, wir sind in Deutschland,
also, aber das ist in der Schweiz, in Winterthur, Also der ist bis zum 3.
Dezember gibt's den CFP und der vom Kongress ist glaube ich,
wie dem auch sei, bis zum 11.
November, aber am 3. gibt's die Ablehnungen.
Und Zusagen vielleicht auch schon.
Genau, also man kann ja einreichen, darauf sollten wir hinweisen.
Freuen sich über Einreichungen zur Informationstechnologie, Digitalisierung
und deren Auswirkungen auf unsere Gesellschaft und es wäre cool,
wenn wir den CFP in der nächsten LMP Folge erwähnen könnten.
Haben wir hiermit gemacht und unter cfp .winterkongress .ch könnt ihr dann eure Einreichung machen.
Und dann machen wir weiter mit dem Elevate Festival in Graz,
das gerade angekündigt wurde.
Das ist ein netzpolitisches und kulturelles Festival, was seit 2017 in Graz
stattfindet, mit sehr hochkarätigen Speakerinnen aus der ganzen Welt.
Cory Doktorow war letztes Jahr dort.
Und die haben wirklich guten netzpolitischen Content und gute Party,
was sehr selten in Österreich ist. Deswegen gehe ich da gerne hin.
Und das ist jedes Jahr im Grazer Schlossberg und in anderen Locations rund um
die schnuckelige Studentenstadt Graz.
Und wird auch wiederum nächstes Jahr zwischen 28.
Februar und 3. März dort stattfinden. Nähere Informationen unter elevate .at.
Graz, ne?
Kürbiskernöl.
Trinkt ihr da Kürbiskernöl dann?
Ja, am besten zu deinem steirischen Backhändler.
Es gibt eigentlich nicht so geile Partys in Österreich, aber in Graz.
Wir waren da noch nie. Warst du da schon mal?
In Graz?
Nein, auf dem Elevate Festival.
Nee, hab mich ja noch nicht eingeladen.
Da bringt sie mich auf eine Idee.
Ich auch nicht. Ich war da auch noch nicht. 28. Februar, 3. März.
Da bin ich glaube ich nicht in Deutschland, aber auch nicht in Österreich.
Ist da nicht arschkalt da?
Na das geht März, Graz ist ziemlich nah an Italien das ist meistens schon so,
da reicht die dünne Jacke.
Die dünne Jacke, also für Events mit der dünnen Jacke bin ich unter Umständen zu haben.
Okay, wenn das so nah an Italien ist dann kann man ja da Pizza mit Kürbiskernöl zum Beispiel.
Ja ich kann aber nicht.
Schade.
Du kannst aber nicht?
Bin ich nicht in Deutschland.
Achso, bist du nicht in Deutschland. So so.
Ja, dann sind wir durch mit unseren Terminen.
Die hört jetzt eh keiner, die ist so leise, die wird wieder keiner hören.
Das schneidet das auf Phonik immer raus.
Schreibt einen Brief, ich beschwöre mich bei denen nochmal.
Das kommt ja auch aus Graz.
Stimmt.
Das ist auch von Nick. Ja, lass mal sehen.
Ja, damit sind wir am Ende der Sendung angekommen.
Hab hier gerade noch ein schönes Bildchen aus dem Internet gesehen.
Steht drauf. If you look carefully.
2001, also in Space Odyssey, 2001. Kennst du das? Stanley Kubrick?
Open the padlock doors, hell.
Genau und da ist die Potbelly doors.
Potbelly doors, ja.
Padlock wäre auch schön. Das geile an dem Film ist ja, da sitzen ja dann die
Crew an so iPad ähnlichen Geräten beim Essen.
Also das war sozusagen der Blick in die Zukunft und das haben sie irgendwie
ganz gut, Stanley Kubrick hat das ganz gut abgebildet, das ist die Zukunft.
Und danach macht die KI ernst.
Danach bringt die KI alle um.
Ja aber ich finde das iPad trotzdem ganz nett. Lass mir doch jetzt hier nicht
das iPad malig machen von dir.
Das iPad war ja auch schon super.
Thomas, vielen vielen Dank für die Ausführungen und deinen unermüdlichen Kampf
für alles, was du da so machst. Ich finde es ja,
ich bin immer, wie soll ich sagen, so geht das ja glaube ich jedem irgendwie mit jemand anders.
Es gibt immer so Dinge, wo man selber gar keinen Bock drauf hätte und man ist
immer total froh, dass andere das toll finden, sich da irgendwie zu engagieren.
Gelingt es dir denn überhaupt noch so?
Also ich meine, hast du da noch Spaß dran?
An der politischen Arbeit schon, ja. Und was genau ist es sozusagen, was dich da kickt?
Wenn du so ein neues Gesetz irgendwie vor dir hast und da mal irgendwie gelesen
und verstanden hast, worum es geht,
dieser Prozess, wo du dir dann vorstellst, in welche Welt führt das und wie
kann man da so ein bisschen gegensteuern und an diesen Text,
der dann gilt für Millionen, halbe Milliarde Menschen noch so ein paar Dinge
ändern, dass vielleicht die Welt, die das erschafft, ein bisschen eine bessere ist.
Also dass man gewisse Dinge abschneidet vom Möglichkeitsbauen,
dass man verhindert, dass gewisse Dinge so kommen.
Ich glaube, dass Gesetzgebung immer noch so einer der Wege ist,
der eine zivilisatorische Errungenschaft ist und den ich auch glaube,
an die Rechtsstaatlichkeit.
Und wo gerade bei Technikfragen es auch jetzt inzwischen ganz stark darum geht,
positive Potenziale endlich zu realisieren und negative Entwicklungen hintanzustellen.
Und auch da passiert gerade einfach noch immer viel und da kann man mitgestalten.
Also ohne diesen Gesetzgebungsaspekt wäre mir auch schon längst langweilig geworden
und ich hätte aufgehört.
Das ist auch so ein bisschen Zeitreise in die Zukunft. Du änderst sozusagen
was in der Vergangenheit, damit sich dann in der Zukunft was ändert.
Ich glaube Zeitreisen sind Missverstanden worden. Man denkt immer so es muss
rückwärts wirken und so weiter.
Nee eigentlich ist Zeitreisen nach vorne in die Zukunft reisen.
Und dann siehst du halt irgendwie, guckst dir die ganze Gesellschaft an und
dann sagst du KI, liest die Gesellschaft und entschlüsselt die geheime Botschaft
und dann sagt die KI, Thomas war's hier.
Also, ich weiß nicht von wem dieser Spruch ist, aber dieses so,
best way to predict the future is to invent it.
Und ich glaube, da ist auch was Inherentmenschliches dabei, zu verstehen,
wie wir ticken und wie es dann, nicht so wie es im Text steht,
nicht so wie es jetzt gemeint ist, sondern wie es dann am Ende wirklich passieren wird.
Das ist ein kreativer Prozess fast.
Und halt auch zu schauen, wie sind die Menschen wirklich, wie werden sie das
Ding jetzt wirklich verwenden und nicht, was steht im Manual, was war die Idee davon.
Und halt dann auch mit Bedacht auf die Gruppen, auf die mächtige Leute gerne
übersehen und die vielleicht eben nicht Teil von irgendeiner technischen Community sind.
Wie wirkt sich das auf die aus? Also ich glaube so an diese Dinge ranzugehen
mit einer Schwäche für die Schwachen, mit einer realistischen Brille auf die
Menschheit, man muss Netzpolitik immer vom Ende her denken, finde ich.
Und so rum macht das für mich immer noch Sinn und auch immer noch Spaß.
Ansonsten würde ich es nicht tun. Ich hätte genügend andere Dinge auch.
Wir müssen jetzt Logbuch Netzpolitik auch unbedingt vom Ende her denken und
die Sendung langsam zu Ende führen.
Hast du noch irgendwas, Linus, was du der Menschheit mitteilen möchtest? Glaubst du nicht?
Gut dann können wir ja unser schönes Outro einspielen.
Das ist ganz gut geworden oder?
Ich hab noch einen Bonus Track eigentlich in die Schaune gelegt.
Dann müssen wir erstmal einen Bonus Track spielen und dann geht's weiter.
Dann sagen wir tschüss. Tschüss Thomas, tschüss alle, bis bald.